la loi d'une femme vendredi à 22h sur
public sénat bonjour bonjour à tous très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour le
rendez vous phare au sénat dans votre
semaine la séance de questions au
gouvernement
ça commence à 15 heures précises en va
tout vous expliquer tout décrypter avec
notre équipe de journalistes avec quand
un calme inquiétant la tribune de presse
de l'hémicycle et de la compta vous
allez nous commenter les questions alors
de quoi on va parler cet après midi
bonjour tam ravi de vous retrouver cette
semaine encore on a retenu trois thèmes
principalement les rixes de jeunes qui
inquiètent par leur niveau de violences
également la vaccination et cette
priorité donnée aux pharmaciens sur les
médecins généralistes cette semaine
enfin troisième thème cette mobilisation
de lecteurs de la culture avec trois
théâtres nationaux occupé en ce moment
un vaste programme à tout à l'heure
quand un cette semaine steve jourdain se
trouve celle des conférences pour toutes
les réactions des ministres des
sénateurs alors qu'ils allaient vous
interviewez pays bas justement que se
passe-t-il précisément dans l'essonne
épicentre des violences entre jeunes
adolescents on en parlera avec le
sénateur l ère du département jean
raymond glück données et puis on
reviendra aussi sur la polémique sur
l'islamo gauchisme a lieu paix de
grenoble on le fera avec le sénateur
écologiste de l'isère guillaume montas à
tout à l'heure steve et puis jean mas
yen autre à streamer politique sur
twitch cette plate forme qu'on ne
présente plus un genre tu échanges tout
l'après midi avec ta communauté sur
cette séance au sénat
hewitt n ya plus en plus de politiques
sur twitter on est très content et on a
hâte de voir ce que les sénateurs les
sénatrices nous réserve comme questions
au gouvernement cet après midi aussi
dans une demi-heure notre face-à-face
opposera le président du groupe de la
majorité présidentielle au sénat
françois patriat aux sénateurs et l'air
la marne rené-paul savary qu'on va
revenir sur la situation sanitaire qui
reste critique et en même temps le
gouvernement qui tente de montrer la
lumière au bout du tunnel
alors pourquoi confinés dans les hauts
de france et pas en ile-de-france
comment s'organise la campagne de
vaccination l'exécutif méthyle le paquet
comme l'a promis jean castex
on en débat à 14h30 mais d'abord le défi
des enseignants face à la laïcité à
l'école en 2020 près de 1000 atteinte à
la laïcité ont été recensés la semaine
dernière un sondage a montré que les
lycéens sont majoritairement favorables
au port de signes religieux ostensibles
dans les établissements scolaires
fracture générationnelle les atteintes à
la laïcité sont elles en hausse
et pourquoi on en parle avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau nathalie delattre
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénatrice ps
de la gironde je précise que vous aviez
présidé la commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste avec nous face
à vous queiroz oulias bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur communiste des
hauts-de-seine et vice président de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation et en visio qu'ovide oblige
nous sommes avec jean louis auduc
bonjour vous êtes directeur honoraire
des études à l'institut militaire membre
du conseil des sages de la laïcité est
également avec nous frédérique rolet
vous êtes secrétaire générale du snes
fsu merci beaucoup d'être avec vous pour
ceux de la alors au tour d'abord et bien
sûr des auditions à ce matin c'est
marquant de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur le séparatisme les
sénateurs s'intéresse donc à la question
de la laïcité à l'école et ils ont
notamment entendu ce matin jean pierre
robin qui est chargé d'une mission
destinée à améliorer la formation à la
laïcité des enseignants dès 2004 l'ex
inspecteur général de l'éducation
alertait sur ce phénomène
marion delpech il est régulièrement cité
dans les médias depuis l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit le rapport au ban du nom de
l'ex inspecteur général est un lointain
écho aux motivations du terroriste
abattu par les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui jean pierre aubin dresse un
constat sur l'évolution de la situation
depuis la rue
de ce rapport jusqu'en 2015 où on n'a
pas fait grand chose on a mis la
poussière sous le tapis et on a laissé
bon au suivant successeur le soin de
régler des problèmes qui sont des
problèmes difficiles certes mais si on
engage la france et qui engagent le long
terme
chargé d'une mission sur la formation à
la laïcité des enseignants jean pierre
robin dit s'être penché sur des études
concernant la réaction des enseignants à
la pénétration de l'islamisme dans les
classes un enseignant sur deux déclare
aujourd'hui s'être auto censurés par
rapport au sondage de 2018
ses 13 points de plus et là c'est ce que
les analystes appellent l'effet pâtit
pour ce lanceur d' alerte c'est le
concept même de laïcité qui est en
danger dans les établissements scolaires
80 à 90% de mu le jeune lycéen musulman
qui exprime une conception punitive de
la laïcité voient la laïcité c'est
quelque chose qui est fait pour qui est
anti musulmans qui est fait pour nous
contraindre qui s'adressent à nous
spécifiquement et qui est une marque
donc j'aime pas du tout les termes mais
les pratiques et d'islamophobie et ce
qui est encore plus inquiétant peut-être
c'est qu'une partie des autres lycéens
non musulmans les suivent dans cette
appréciation
concernant les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur jean pierre
robin réfute l'idée d'un problème
majoritairement lié à l'islamisme
c'est un certain nombre d' idéologie
venue des états unis et pas de l'islam
et qui pervertissent complètement la
recherche française
les conclusions et préconisations de
l'ancien inspecteur général sur ces
différents aspects et sur la formation
des enseignants sont attendus d'ici le
mois d'avril alors nathalie delattre ce
matin jean pierre robin n'a pas mâché
ses mots il estime que la situation
s'est aggravée
il a dit je le cite un la laïcité a
perdu une bataille vis-à-vis de la
jeunesse musulmane très largement
pénétré par l'idéologie islamiste est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat
très sombre nathalie delattre
oui j'avais l'impression d'être quelques
mois
auparavant dans le cadre des auditions
que vous avez emmené dans la commission
d' enquête sur la radicalisation
islamiste c'était nous n'avons pas
découvert beaucoup de choses par rapport
aux propos qui ont été tenus ce matin
c'est vrai nous avions ici mis en
lumière et je crois bien avant les
propos d' emmanuel macron ce déni
politique ce déni institutionnels et
universitaire qui a masqué pendant des
années ce projet collectif mené par
quelques-uns de d'imposer une norme
religieuse au dessus des lois de la
république et c'est ce qui fait que nos
propositions du rapport sont très
largement reprises d'ailleurs dans le
projet doit des principes républicains
moi ce qui m'a un peu déçu dans cette
audition parce que le constat était fort
il a parlé soit naïveté soit de
l'acheter même à un moment donné on se
demande comment on peut faire encore
confiance à l'appareil éducatif pour
enseigner parce que ça a été vraiment
très très noir comme descriptif mais en
tout cas c'est un lanceur dallaire donc
c'est son rôle mais c'est plutôt après
dans la boîte à outils c'est à dire que
bon bien sûr ce constat maintenant le
partage la corse et quelles actions
mettons en place de façon assez choc
parce qu'on s'aperçoit évidemment que le
mal est profond et là je trouve qu'il a
manqué de deux solutions de
préconisations pour quelqu'un qui a une
mission et qui doit apporter des
solutions
je trouve ça inquiétant pierrot zulia ce
que vous êtes d'accord sur le fait qu'il
y a eu un déni sur ce phénomène jean
pierre robin avait alerté dès 2004 son
rapport à l'époque a été enterré très
critiqué ces positions ont été jugés
islamophobes les politiques de tous
bords ont-ils eu un aveuglement sur ce
sujet et puis enfin pour le coup on
parle pas du tout de la gauche comme on
peut vous parler parfois parce que là il
a aussi notamment visé françois fillon
en disant tu allumes la poussière avait
été miss oui tu as bien de choses
d'abord moi j'appartiens à une famille
politique et puis j'ai une histoire
familiale qui fait que je suis athée
mais on est athée depuis 4 quelle
génération que on peut pas nous accuser
d'être oui angélique par rapport aux
religions
1 il ya même eu dans l'histoire de mon
parti des violences anti clérical plutôt
d'assurer c'est ça voilà voilà
on peut le dire comme ça donc moi je
suis très tranquille sur ce sursaut sur
l'ensemble est ce qu'il ya des gens
pareils c'est là que les alertes n'ont
pas toutes été entendues
c'est là que j'ai un problème oui et
j'avais questionné sur ce sujet monsieur
monsieur aubin ce matin il m'a pas
répondu sur ce point parce que le le
centre national d'études des systèmes
scolaires qui est un organisme officiel
ah c'est une grande enquête seize mille
élèves 2020 et montre exactement inverse
c'est à dire que ce qu'ils voient lui le
cne sco c'est une diminution du poids de
la religion dans les établissements et
le cne sco nous dit 90% des élèves
français sont d'accord avec la laïcité
alors qui croire le cne sco
moi j'essaie données statistiques jeu
bien les comparer le tableau à tour
noire pour vous en faites laïcité aussi
qu'elle est la notion de la société
danton fait référence et il faut faire
attention
la laïcité c'est pas l'anti religion 1
et pourtant il ya un vrai un vrai sujet
à faire attention à ce sujet et je
crains malheureusement que avec le
projet de loi nous allions vers quelque
chose qui soit la volonté de chasser
totalement de la sphère publique la
religion ce qui n'est pas ma position
certaines religions le christ au ciel
lance d'ailleurs un appel aujourd'hui
dans le figaro on va regarder d'autres
chiffres sur les atteintes à la laïcité
en 2020 alors on parle de 935
signalements entre septembre 2019 et
mars 2020 les chiffres sont relativement
stables mais bon encore faut-il que les
signalements et été effectués 45% des
faits au collège 37% dans les écoles
primaires 18% au lycée et puis la moitié
des signalements dans six académies
créteil grenoble normandie toulouse
versailles et nice frédérique rolet
comment se manifeste aujourd'hui les
atteintes à la laïcité à l'école est ce
que pour vous aujourd'hui il y a plus
d'auto censure de la part des
enseignants aujourd'hui qu'hier
ce que je voudrais si on veut parler de
laïcité il faut d'abord s'entendre sur
le terme et non pas avoir l'idée d'une
laïcité punitive qui sont anti
religieuse à hésiter c'est la liberté
justement je pense que déjà c'est une
bonne chose de le rappeler c'est aussi
ni minimisé les incidents mais ne pas
caricaturer non plus et ce que nous
regrettons souvent c'est
un discours qui tend à amplifier les
phénomènes de façon y compris injuste
mais je discutais récemment avec des
collègues de l'académie de créteil où il
ya beaucoup d'établissements qui sont
souvent pointés du doigt et nous disent
les preuves de laïcité ce n'est pas
notre préoccupation prioritaire
ce sont les salles des profs ce n'est
pas le sujet dont nous discutons
prioritairement et se regarde le sondage
de l'ifop la qui avait été pour la
fondation jean jaurès qui a été
largement commentée je trouve que il ya
eu des lectures extrêmement biaisée de
ce sondage parce que quand on dit et ses
tirs pris par jean pierre aubin les
enseignants se se censure ça veut dire
quoi on je sais qu'il ya des collègues
qui disent je fais je prends des
précautions
je choisis la méthode pédagogique qui me
permet de faire partager un certain
nombre de des valeurs de la laïcité aux
élèves
mais en choisissant de ne pas choquer
dès le départ et s'est pas vue comme une
auto censure s'est vu comme une
stratégie une stratégie pédagogique elle
est cantonnée à la question est il seul
match le plus difficile à enseigner sa
course en d'aider des gens qui ont
répondu qu'ils disent qu'est ce sont
régulièrement nous censurer les 95%
autres auront eu une fois dans toute
leur carrière éventuel membres dont vous
voyez alors après il ya des phénomènes
on le sait ça se ça peut être des choses
très concrètes
ces refus d'aller visiter une église ou
une cathédrale dans le cadre d'un cours
ou d'histoire géographie ou d'arts
plastiques
ça peut être la protestation dans
certains enseignements qui sont souvent
les mêmes c'est les sciences et vie de
la terre ça peut être là
la philosophie l'histoire de certains
concepts mais encore une fois en face
très souvent et heureusement les équipes
parviennent en dialoguant avec les
familles avec les élèves à faire le
chemin qui amène les élèves à comprendre
qu' il s'agit pas de s'attaquer à sa foi
en tant que personne mais d'établir ce
que doit faire l'école c'est-à-dire des
savoirs scientifiques qui permettent
l'esprit critique jean louis auduc
frédérique rolet en parlait à l'instant
effectivement il ya un sondage de la
semaine dernière qui a fait beaucoup
parler de lui
un sondage auprès des lycéens qui montre
que 52% des lycéens français sont
favorables au port de signes religieux
ostensibles dans les établissements le
sondage précise également que 38 %
veulent une loi autorisant le port du
burkini
est-ce que ce sondage vous inquiète
et puis petite question justement lié à
ce que ce que disait très bien quel rôle
à l'instant est ce que il ne réduit pas
la question de la laïcité aussi à la
cohabitation avec avec l'islam alors
premièrement ce sondage m'inquiète parce
qu'ils révèlent quelque chose
on voit également au niveau de la
situation des enseignants et que
j'évoquerai tout à l'heure c'est la
rupture entre une vision purement
théorique juridique de la laïcité et de
ce point de vue là le sondage ifop
montrent que les six que les jeunes sont
extrêmement claires juridiquement sur ce
qu'est la laïcité et ont peint la loi de
1905 sondage intéressant par contre sur
l'application concrète en termes de
liberté conscience en termes
effectivement du rôle de l'école qui est
émancipateur et voit qu'il n'ya pas de
connexion pour les jeunes entre une
vision théorique ce qu'avait confirmé le
ps co et l'application dans le quotidien
pour moi c'est un vrai problème
pédagogique
aujourd'hui
et pourtant que de le montrer vous le
rappeler fortement et dans
l'enseignement primaire
c'était quelque chose qu'il ya 5 6 ans
étaient marginales aujourd'hui c'est 37
% plus bas tiers des atteintes à la
laïcité
deuxième élément on voit aujourd'hui des
enseignants que j'appellerais désemparés
parce que souvent la formation qui l'on
est et est une forme théorique et non
pas une formation liés à la classe est à
l'étude de deux cas et au concret à la
pratique de la classe pour moi il a
trois démarches qui doivent être fait de
manière importante aux mirman dans leur
formation initiale
il faut que la laïcité soit travaillé à
la matière qu'ils vont enseigner
si un gâteau ni d'une formation en
articulation avec la tique de place une
base et spiritueux compte deux cas il
peut seulement y développe une chose
imagine souvent conseil des sages et on
découvre que ça permet progressiez ces
déformations en établissements scolaires
réunissant tous les personnels de
l'établissement des personnels
administratifs de services au personnel
de secrétariat de direction aux
enseignants et aux surveillants s'est
offert une communauté du natif vivante
sans leader sur la laïcité il y signifie
libre et vous me permettez l'expression
une communauté éducative et vente
solidaire c'est le meilleur rempart ou
communautaristes qui se développe dans
un certain nombre d'établissements
soyons clairs a effectivement
aujourd'hui 5 à 10% d'établissements en
difficulté et il faut centrer là dessus
mais on
regroupe les uns en danse est une
occasion par et par rapport à di
difficultés des hôtesses passion sur
lequel ils n'ont pas été préparés
pendant leur formation initiale
on va parler effectivement donc de ce
sujet et ça fait consensus il faut mieux
former les enseignants à la laïcité et
pour l'instant ce qui est prévu
effectivement ne semble pas à la hauteur
écouté ce matin jean pierre robin sur ce
sujet en 2018 plutôt 6% des
enseignements post déclaré avoir reçu
une formation à la laïcité 6%
donc le besoin je n'ai pas les attentes
mais les besoins de formation sont
énormes
ne faudrait-il pas mettre dans la loi
quelque chose qui impose à l'éducation
nationale de former rapidement la masse
des enseignants en poste et la
l'employeur éducation nationale a
davantage de maîtrise de l'outil de
formation pour contrôler la nature de
ces formations
frédéric relève vous êtes d'accord il
faut mieux former les enseignants les
former tout court pour qu'ils soient
moins désemparé pour ce que nous c'était
les propos de jean bio dit qu'à
l'instant on sait que les chiffres sur
les atteintes à la ici à la laïcité ils
sont plutôt suis aidé à lui parce que
parfois même les attaques ne sont plus
perçus comme tels aujourd'hui alors
qu'ils fassent mieux former les
enseignants les enseignants français
notamment disposent très très peu de
formation continue c'est un fait avéré
par rapport à d'autres d'autres pays
le faire aussi en lien avec la
didactique delà de la discipline c'est
vrai que les problèmes ne se posent pas
de la même façon si on est professeur
d'éducation physique et sportive pour
auxerre de philosophie ou d'histoire
géographie par exemple
effectivement il ya de vrais moments de
difficultés pour
pour les enseignants ils ont besoin d
tard mais ils ont besoin de formation
ils ont besoin aussi d'une cohésion
surtout de tout de toute l'équipe de
toute l'équipe pédagogique et éducative
et de réponse qui soit commune qui passe
d'abord par tout ce qui peut être le
dialogue c'est vraiment quand le
dialogue est épuisé qu'on a
éventuellement recours et ça existe à
des mesures plus coercitives mais ça ça
pue ce que ça suppose véritablement qui
est cette cohésion dont on n'a pas
toujours les effets et dans un entretien
au monde un d'ailleurs il ya le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a expliqué
combien la laïcité était pour lui bien
une valeur essentielle je le cite la
laïcité n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement du système scolaire elle et
son socle fondamental nathalie delattre
on voit il ya toute une communication du
gouvernement sur la laïcité de la part
de jean-michel blanquer air qui a mis en
place le conseil des sages de la laïcité
les équipes valeurs de la république
mais au niveau de la formation ça paraît
vraiment pauvre pour l'instant oui tout
à fait c'est à dire que c'est bien ce
que nous craignons l époque de la
commission denquête séclier des annonces
fortes et le ministre blanquart et fait
vraiment des annonces fortes déterminées
tout comme gabriel attal qui était à la
jeunesse à cette époque là où nous
avions eu vraiment du flottement c'est
avec la ministre des sports qui
nous avait avoué qu on pouvait peut-être
s'entendre sur la notion de laïcité
voilà elle n'est pas élastique enfin
elle c'est une c'est une valeur mais il
ya un décalage entre ces deux annonces
fortes et ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui
dans la loi ou en tout cas ce vers quoi
on a envie de tendre c'est aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'une communauté
éducative qui puisse de façon solidaire
et ça je rejoins l'intervenant précédent
pouvoir faire face à cette problématique
qui est de remise en cause aujourd'hui
de cette notion de laïcité parce que
c'est vrai que quand on interroge les
jeunes sur la laïcité
certes ils ont peut-être une approche
juridique mais aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'elle est attaquée de toutes parts et
qu'elle n'est plus un ciment de notre
notre république et ce qui a été mis en
lumière c'est que c'est étonnant parce
que dans tous les métiers on parle de la
formation tout au long de la vie et à
ceux qui vont former à l'esprit critique
à ceux qui préparent les hommes et les
femmes de demain
eh bien on offre pas ce système de
formation continue et je pense que là il
ya énormément effectivement à faire
pierrot zulia c'est d'autant plus que la
laïcité c'est un conte est un concept
compliqué à enseigner à comprendre
appliqué on a vu que peut-être la
compréhension était plutôt bonne de la
part de les lycéens des lycées remet ça
veut pas forcément dire qu'ils sont
passés à la pratique
oui et la laïcité c'est d'autant plus
difficile à comprendre quand on sait par
la laïcité du projet républicain et de
la citoyenneté qui est fondamental la
république sait faire d'un corps social
makuch citoyens diverses un bloc qu'à un
projet collectif commun
or aujourd'hui cette idée qui est majeur
qui est con qu'on doit la révolution
française de 1789
bien évidemment il est menacé par un
individualisme primaire des sens anglo
saxon libre
alou ce qui compte c'est l'individu
lui-même séparer de tout lien social de
toulouse citoyenneté quand vous avez une
perte de repères par rapport la
république vous considérez que ce qui
est important c'est vous la couleur de
votre peau vaut le genre votre religion
et alors là on a un travail immense
affaire 1 moi j'aime beaucoup ferdinand
buisson un qui est l'un des auteurs de
la loi de 1905 qui disait le problème de
la république c'est qu'elle manque d'eau
républicain ce qu'il nous faut c'est des
républicains c'est des gens qui
aujourd'hui réenchante le lien
fondamental le lien citoyen avec la
république pour conclure je voudrais que
l'on s'intéresse pour la troisième
partie de ce débat la question de
l'enseignement supérieur parce que entre
l' enquête sur l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université demandé par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
et puis ces derniers jours la sphère de
l'iep de grenoble où deux enseignants
ont été publiquement accusé
d'islamophobie et bénéficie désormais
d'une protection policière c'est un
sujet qu'il y à aussi à l'université à
ce sujet ans va rejoindre d'un style
jourdain il est avec le sénateur de
l'isère et président du groupe
écologiste guillaume quintard millions
vantard
bonjour cette polémique autour de lieux
paix de grenoble qu'est ce qu'elle vous
inspire qu est ce qui m inspire déjà
déjà condamné condamné ce qui ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'est les
syndicats étudiants qui relaie les
syndicats étudiants se sont excusés sur
effectivement ce ce tweet j'irai même
malheureux mais en tout cas ce qui est
ce qui est condamnable c'est le fait de
mettre à la vindicte populaire
dd non d'universitaires de les placarder
sur les murs donc ça c'est des méthodes
qui ne sont absolument pas acceptable
on a d'autres solutions pour régler les
problèmes à l'intérieur de l'université
via la direction et c'est donc c'est
bien sûr une condamnation sans précédent
mais c'est surtout derrière tout ça
c'est l'ambiance délétère qui règne dans
les universités qui règne dans notre
dans notre pays je rappelle qu'il ya peu
de temps
plus de 600 universitaires ont été mis
aussi en pâture sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les sites internet sous
mr d'islamo d'islamophobie et je pense
qu'on peut pas on peut pas on peut pas
accepter on peut pas accepter 7,7 cette
situation là et il me semble que la
ministre vidal est responsable c'est à
dire cette chasse aux sorcières qui a
été qui a été initiée le gouverneur
gauchisme c'est ce que l'islam aux
gauchistes oui effectivement j'ai eu sur
sur l'ailé des six cents 600
universitaire un conte était taxé
d'islamiste gauchistes qui ont été mis
sur sur les sur les sites sur les sites
internet
alors ce qu'on peut pas accepter on peut
pas accepter cette solution et on voit
bien que cette chasse aux sorcières on
voit où ça nous mène dans une dans une
division profonde et qui moi me paraît
particulièrement inquiétant leur
revenant peut être rallier ep de
grenoble principal syndicat étudiant de
sciences po persiste et signe r il
demande est bien des sanctions à
l'encontre des deux professeurs accusé
d'islamophobie qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez à ce syndicat moi d'abord c'est
d'abord sur les sanctions
je pense qu à six il y à des faits jeudi
il ya des procédures qui sont clairement
clairement encadrée 10 à moins bien sûr
et puis et puis il ya des il ya des
procédures qui sont clairement encadrée
via la direction de déposer une plainte
ou un recours via via la direction et
que les choses sont en cours mais en
tout cas on ne peut pas accepter des
méthodes et de mettre en pâture des des
universitaires et direct quel qu'il soit
et on voit bien que ce que la situation
dans dans lequel donc elle qu'on se
trouve n'est plus n'est plus acceptable
que cette cette chasse aux sorcières et
que franchement je pense qu'il faut
revenir à un petit peu de raison là où
en train de nous emmener le gouvernement
actuel n'est pas acceptable c'est pas
comme si on n'était pas dans une
problématique particulière dans notre
pays on atteint plus de 10 millions de
pauvres
on a des des étudiants qui sont obligés
de chercher à manger dans des délits
fils dans des files d'attentes que fait
le gouvernement par rapport à ça je
pense que c'est s'est recentré on a
besoin d'union nationale dans cette
situation particulièrement diogon tard
les deux en signant en question ont été
mis sous protection policière protection
policière
c'est grave de être enseignant
aujourd'hui c'est un métier à risque et
bien sûr que c'est grave je fais chez
jeu je les congeler condamné c'est
particulièrement grave
on ne peut pas accepter cette situation
là on ne peut pas accepter que des
universiades universitaire semi comme ça
comme ça en pâture mais pourquoi on
arrive à de telles idées telle situation
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se pose des
questions
la responsabilité de frédéric vidal qui
a initié cette chasse aux sorcières et
on voit bien que ça ne mène à rien si ce
n'est à de la division merci beaucoup
dit on retarde avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci merci merci à steve pour cette
première réaction votre réaction et ne
reste vraiment quelques minutes jean
louis auduc qu'est-ce qui vous marque
vous dans cette affaire la possibilité
d'aborder ces sujets avec sérénité dans
l'enseignement supérieur le lieu du
débat contradictoire normalement et puis
guillaume contart estime lui qu'il y a
aussi une responsabilité de la part du
gouvernement dans le fait d'avoir un
petit peu hystériser le débat avec ce
procès fait à l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université non mais moi je crois qu'il
ya un véritable enjeu aujourd'hui de
faire de l'université rig le lieu du
débat argumenté et à de la tension de la
sécession je condamne absolument
l'attitude qui a dit m honneur en jeu
capture des enseignants et des
[Musique]
conseillers napoléon iii qu'on l'avait
traitée d' islam au filet mais vous êtes
des islamo scott ce terme si
effectivement il ya du racisme anti
musulman
on le condamne en tant qu raciste mais
de grâce que l'université retrouve
effectivement sérénité on vous entend
assez mal je suis obligé de vous de vous
interrompre pierre aux liasses vous
qu'est ce qui vous choque dans cette
affaire'' ya plusieurs choses qui
peuvent choquer un les propos des
enseignants l'impossibilité d'avoir un
débat au sein de l'université sur ces
sujets la position des syndicats
l'ensemble du contexte
moi je dis
halte au feu halte au feu il faut que
chacun tout le monde agisse en
responsabilité et reviennent en effet
comme le disait très justement mon
collègue monsieur monsieur duc un débat
rationnel où on oppose argument contre
argument démonstration contre nos
démonstrations et où on me donne des
articles qui montre que telle ou telle
idéologie est représentée ou pas
représentée par ailleurs je rejoins
totalement guillaume gontard il ya au
sein de l'université des procédures pour
gérer ces conflits les réseaux sociaux
ne sont pas des lieux d'intermédiation 1
est ce que chacun nous devrions faire
c'est l'équité l'équité dans le sens de
dans le sens juridique mais aussi quitté
les réseaux sociaux pour revenir au
débat est revenu au campus et revenir à
l'agora on a besoin de ça y compris la
ministre
il comprit 2006 choc nathalie delattre
s'est aussi bien sûr que ce type
d'affichage sa lieu quelques mois après
laffaire samuel paty et qu'on le sait
afficher en parlant de fascisme ou
d'islamophobie des enseignants dans ce
contexte et bien cela forcément choque
tout le monde et cela peut être
dangereux
oui vous savez on a une frustration avec
jacqueline eustache brinio dans la
commission dans ta qu une enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste que nous avions
commencé à auditionner la conférence des
présidents des deux universités qui nous
a un peu expliqué circulez ya rien à
voir il n'y a pas de problème à
l'université alors qu'on avait des
retours sur des problématiques assez
prégnant et malheureusement la coville
est arrivé et nous n'avons pas pu faire
des visites d'université comme nous le
souhaitions et je pense que ça
mériterait effectivement que nous ayons
une suite de cette commission d' enquête
spécifiquement sur l'université parce
que l'on sent bien aujourd'hui qu'il
faut que on
on arrive à retrouver un dialogue apaisé
mais que comme dans l'école
il ya eu un déni et que c'est des
idéologies aujourd'hui ne peuvent plus
s'imposer comme elles le font au coeur
de notre université donc il faut pouvoir
s'en défendre donc j'appelle moi une
commission denquête ou une mission
d'information sur le sujet vous appelez
une commission denquête le mot de la fin
à frédérique rolet puisque bien là
encore ce sont comme des enseignants qui
sont visés normal de crainte pour leur
sécurité après l affaire samuel pâtit on
voit aujourd'hui l'ampleur que ce type
d'affaires peuvent avoir oui non bien
sûr condamnation sans faille de la
procédure procédé qui consiste à jeter
en pâture des collègues et comme ça a
été dit il ya des procédures
s'ils sont tenus des propos racistes le
racisme tombent sous le coup de la loi
c'est un set à new delhi donc il faut
laisser les procédures se mettre en
place et il est vrai qu'il faudrait
aussi que le gouvernement et notamment
la mise de l'enseignement supérieur mais
aussi une mise de l'éducation ne jette
pas de l'huile sur le feu il s'agit de
dire que l'école et l'université doivent
être des lieux où on a des débats
contradictoires des lieux où justement
émancipateur ça se fasse parler savoir
ça passe par le débat et non pas par
l'anathème voilà des débats sera et
contradictoires merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
la séance de questions d'actu commence
dans maintenant trente mille qui va
d'ailleurs y avoir une question sur ce
sujet
nos journalistes sont en plastique
lourdin salle des conférences jean macé
avec sa communauté sur twitter pour
senna stream
et puis quand un calme est dans
l'hémicycle qu'est ce qui va marquer
cette séance de questions d'actualité
pour vous content en tout cas oui
effectivement entame mais bien une
question prévue en milieu de séance de
pascal allizard un sénateur a l'air sûr
mais bien la polémique un client flat
lieu p2 grenoble mais trois autres
sujets nous intéresse particulièrement
aujourd'hui avec par exemple la question
de céline boulay sp rogner elle est
sénatrice apparentés l air
de paris elle va interroger le
gouvernement sur les rixes de jeunes
mineurs qui semblent se multiplier ces
dernières semaines avec des bagarres de
plus en plus violente
elle est élue elle même du 16e
arrondissement des affrontements ont
justement eu lieu hier devant le lycée
lafontaine dans son arrondissement avec
des blessés à l'armé blanche mais la
sénatrice nous a confié aussi avoir été
très choqué par la mort d'une jeune ado
dans le val d'oise roué de coups et jeté
dans la seine par deux camarades elle a
été retrouvée inanimée
hier il s'agit donc pour la sénatrice
aujourd hui d'interroger l'escaladé de
la violence de ces adolescents et la
question vous vous en doutez est
adressée à gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'intérieur deux autres sujets nous
intéresse particulièrement tam on attend
des questions sur la vaccination
notamment cette préférence accordée aux
pharmaciens sur les médecins
généralistes cette semaine bien cela
interroge certains groupes politiques et
enfin une question sur les mobilisations
dans le monde de la culture se sont
actuellement trois théâtres nationaux
qui sont occupés dont l'odéon le théâtre
de l'odéon le voisin du sénat tam et oui
c'est juste à côté effectivement quand
un merci beaucoup pour tout ces
explications vous retrouve dans un petit
peu moins d'une demi heure chaque oeil à
présent pour le face à face le président
du groupe r dpi sénat françois patriat
bonjour bonjour et le sénateur et l'air
de la marne rené-paul savary bonjour
joue on va parler avec vous de ce sujet
qui nous occupe depuis maintenant on va
dire plus d'un an la situation sanitaire
on va commencer en parlant stratégie
vaccinale après l'audition ce matin
d'alain fischer devant la commission des
affaires sociales résumé par cécile 6
souvent l'astra zeneca fait l'objet
d'une polémique injuste lors de son
audition alain fischer a tenu à
réhabiliter l'image de ce vaccin mal
aimé pourtant aussi efficace que les
autres selon lui mais quinze derniers
jours sont venues des données d'abord
des causes puis l'angleterre montrant
que ce vaccin est en fait aussi efficace
que le vaccin files heures pour obtenir
une protection par exemple à l'égard des
hospitalisations
y compris chez les personnes âgées parce
que là bas ils ont vacciné les personnes
âgées
les recommandations ont légitimement
changé et maintenant il est donc
possible de vacciner à tout âge avec le
vaccin sera zeneca faire de la pédagogie
sur ce vaccin surtout auprès des
personnels soignants
réticent à ce qu'on leur administre
voilà la stratégie suivie par le
monsieur vaccin du gouvernement qui
encore la place même s'il faut aller
vite pour de la pédagogie pour la
concertation pour de l'explication avec
tous les professionnels de santé
maintenant si ce travail s'avérait
insuffisant ils ont dans 15 jours je
donnais le baril après six je pense que
la notion de l'obligation vaccinale se
discute
une obligation vaccinale compliqué pour
plusieurs sénateurs qui ont dénoncé la
stigmatisation des personnels soignants
comme la sénatrice communiste laurence
cohen lui ont dit oh là là ils sont pas
vaccinés c'est pas bien
alors que on sait pertinemment qu'on
manque de doses crois qu'il faut faire
attention dans la façon dont nous
communiquons peut pas hier les applaudir
et aujourd'hui avoir un
quand même un discours de
culpabilisation
les sénateurs ont également dénoncé la
culpabilisation des médecins libéraux
pourtant engagée depuis la semaine
dernière dans la campagne de vaccination
qui ont dû stopper net cette semaine par
manque de doses alain fischer a reconnu
une erreur de communication du
gouvernement
je pense que cette affaire sur le plan
la communication a été très mal traités
il faut aussi relativiser les choses
c'est que le les médecins en fait dès la
fin de cette semaine
devons pouvoir recommander à nouveau des
vaccins et donc il y aura pas vraiment
d'interruption et que les doses les
doses commandées pour être administrés
alain fischer a également annoncé une
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
si la france reçoit les doses prévues la
vaccination des plus de 50 ans pourrait
commencer en mai et s'ouvrir dès le mois
de juin au reste de la population ce
matin rené paul savary cette audition
elle a parlé notamment de la question
des réticences des soignants à se faire
vacciner
est ce que vous êtes choqués par ces
réticences ou par le procès qui leur est
fait aujourd'hui on entend de plus en
plus de critiques vis-à-vis de certains
de ces soignants qui montre de la
méfiance
oui moi j'en suis désolé 1
je pense que ça va ça va changer info
faire confiance quand même je crois
qu'il ya une prise de conscience un
geste tout à fait essentiel maintenant
on dispose effectivement le vaccin qui
sont complètement efficaces donc faut y
aller mais c'est vrai qu'au début il ya
une certaine méfiance bon d'otages n'ont
jamais remis et des aides soignants et
voilà encore convaincre avant tout
convaincre et puis d'ici là c'est moi
j'ai toujours dit que je l'étais pas je
t'ai favorable avant d éventuellement
obligatoire pour un certain nombre de
personnes
ce vaccin pourquoi pas mais si avec la
pédagogie on arrive à pas le rendre
obligatoire et une prise de conscience
très bien donc je voudrais devenir c'est
que ya pas de concurrence entre
pharmaciens et médecins faut arrêter ça
faut pas dire ça c'est pas vrai d'autre
part mais le droit de comment et que
yadier des stocks
les médecins vont chez les femmes le
professeur fisher dit également quelque
chose que qui m'a interpellé lorsque
nous l'avons auditionné c'est que
l'histoire des médecins généralistes est
passé mais non il ya eu un vrai quoi
d'ailleurs elle a reconnu il ya une
maladresse terrible puisque ils ont eu
un temps d'adaptation un peu long donc
on a constaté effectivement il y avait
400 2012 de rab et le gouvernement a dit
toujours très administratif ont fait
c'est l'administration mais les 400000
vous avez qu à vacciner dans le week-end
à l'aise il faut sauf que derrière
maintenant qu'on livre aux pharmaciens
des médecins sont organisées cette
semaine par exemple nous on allait
remonter de plusieurs cabinets médicaux
ne collectent travailler encore 200
vaccination organisée toko lauder banon
maintenance et formation quand le
congrès que ça c'est là où il ya des
erreurs de communication qui les
arrières et d'administration disons le
qui font que ça décourage un peu du
monde
françois patriat erreur d'administration
erreur coup de communication qui du coup
a fait qu'on a utilisé beaucoup de stock
d'un coup mais du coup on appuie cette
semaine qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'entends parler des difficultés je vous
entends pas parler de ce qui marche
l'objectif 4 millions de personnes
vaccinées fin février donc y sommes
arrivés
l'objectif du million de personnes
vaccinées le 15 avril nous y arriverons
15 millions de personnes le 15 juin nous
y arriverons et 30 millions les
personnes droit de vacciner l'été nous y
arriverons alors il ya chaque jour des
difficultés j'entends bien que ce que
veut le gouvernement ce qu'ils pensent
docteur savary ne le démentira pas c'est
que le vaccin aller au plus près les
patients les médecins c'est pas toujours
facile parce qu'il faut qu'ils prennent
rendez-vous dans leurs cabinets doivent
commander les doses ils ont eu de
surcroît des problèmes administratifs à
régler les difficultés bien inutile mais
dans le même temps j'entends les
pharmaciens depuis le début depuis la
fin de notre décembre qui me disaient
nous on a l'habitude
les gens viennent chez nous et du
demande ils nous disent je voudrais à ce
que pouvaient nous vacciner c'est le
plus facile à l'hémicyle pharmaciens ce
que les gens qui vont chez le pharmacien
souvent c'est pas comme le rendez vous
avec le médecin s'est pas autres donc
aujourd'hui le gouvernement fasse en
sorte que distribuer les vaccins d'abord
dans les zones prioritaires
d'abord dans les zones prioritaires
ensuite là où c'est plus près des gens
le plus facile pour être administrés je
crois que c'est comme ça il va y avoir
une montée en puissance de la production
vaccinale à partir du 15 mars ou début
avril
à bien voir que le problème qui
s'étaient posés pour les masses canon
suppose pour les vaccins au début parce
qu'il n'a pas de produits assez on le
sait bien et séduction mais une plaque
pour le pool pour le astrazeneca
le gouvernement l'avait gardé parce
qu'il pensait que le personnel soignant
il avait envoyé dans les hôpitaux et
dans les lieux où il ya des soignants
vous savez la semaine dernière sur votre
plateau savez il ya des gens qui ne
voulaient pas se faire soigner il y
avait une aide soignante à domicile qui
avait 40 ans et qui me disait c'est
dramatique peut pas me faire vacciner
il ya vraiment à chaque fois on entend
les deux j'entends chaque fois tout et
son contraire entre les immunologue
entre les ce qu'ils veulent pour confine
ceux qui veulent pas qu'on peaufine
c'est pareil avec les vaccins donc c'est
vrai c'est vrai que compte tenu malgré
tout du manque de production de doses on
n'a pas les doses qu'on voudrait partout
aujourd'hui moi aussi j'ai des médecins
qui me disent passer deux semaines j'ai
vendent aux caisses que les choses se
dégradent aux pourtant bien mais en même
temps vous avez vu ce qui se passe dans
la région en or aux côtés de dunkerque
que là on envoyait le maximum de vaccins
comme on l'avait fait d'ailleurs un
bourgogne franche comté au début du mois
de janvier où il y avait on était
vraiment vraiment en surtension
on a eu beaucoup d'effet et maintenant
on est vraiment retombée on est bien en
dessous de la moyenne nationale
ça marchait dans ce contexte en tout cas
qui reste difficile l'exécutif veut
montrer un petit peu de lumière au bout
du tunnel a on a entendu des prises de
paroles des manuels marque rond parlant
de quatre à six semaines et puis ce
matin il ya jean baptiste lemoyne dans
la matinale de public sénat a voulu
montrer que la reprise se prépare
écouter on évoquait la mi-avril comme
étant un peu un moment pivot
où on allait pouvoir et bien travaillé
aussi un certain nombre de réouverture
d'activités en tous les cas le présent
la publique police nous a demandé d'y
travailler donc moi la semaine prochaine
je réunirai d'ailleurs au cours de trois
réunions avec mon collègue alain griset
notamment isabelle borne les acteurs du
de l'hôtellerie de la restauration de
l'événementiel et serra pour travailler
à ces conditions de reprises ses
modalités de reprise
à quoi peuvent aussi se projeter ont
fait ces travaux maintenant pour pouvoir
et bien donner de la visibilité
vous le voyez d'ici la fin du mois de
mars le secrétaire d'état au tourisme
qui laisse d'ailleurs des espoirs aussi
pour les vacances de pâques
rené paul savary dans ce contexte on
sent l'exécutif qui a aussi besoin de
montrer bien qu'il y a une fin du tunnel
et qu'il ya une lumière au bout
on sait que la reprise se prépare ça
montre site ils veulent avoir une part
louis mais séparément de la parole ça ni
sur yon prudent soyons prudents on voit
ce qui se passe dans différents
départements
on peut pas tenir des chantiers ce qui
est important c'est préparer une reprise
qu'en nocera mais il faut préparer une
reprise
ouais donner des dates se donne un
espoir très bien je vous comprend un
touchant mais sauf que si jamais ça se
réalise pas comme ça au fait des déçus y
a rien de pire que de faire des déçus
faut arrêter de situer les valses op la
vaccination c'est exactement ça c'est
pour ça que je déplore pour l'histoire
des médecins généralistes
on arrive à avoir les vaccins maintenant
ils sont pas assez vite et on se tire
une balle sur pied parce que ce concours
ils sont inscrits maintenant les gens
enlevés il ya plus à faut éviter tout ce
genre alors c'est pas facile hein
toujours beaucoup d'humilité dans la
proche mais le court terme il ya parfois
une communication de court terme qui
peut être intéressante dans les stands
présents mais qui derrière peut être
catastrophique scène se réalise pas
l'espoir on doit le donner aux gens va
sortir de la sphère surtout on se fait
vacciner donc en est le message que je
souhaite faire passer
voici dire aux gens vous avez des
vaccins ils sont tous efficace tous tous
tous même lastras zeneca d'une grande
efficacité faut aller se faire vacciner
faut avoir considéré le message après
c'est comme ça qu'on aura effectivement
le bout du tunnel
quels délais moi il ya un message qui
paraît peut-être moins clair
c'est la différence qui se fait
aujourd'hui dans le confinement entre
l'île de france
alors que les taux d'incidence en seine
saint denis sont nés dans nos temps mais
supérieur au pas-de-calais le
pas-de-calais qui en revanche est
confiné le week-end
est-ce que et bien c'est pas un petit
peu joué avec le feu aujourd'hui et
françois patriat ce matin valérie
pécresse ise que l'épidémie est en train
de monter en flèche en ile-de-france en
rien ceux qui chaque jour crie au loup
crient aux restrictions un cri au
confinement total puis ceux qui disent
laissez nous respirer lieu de culture
dit bon je crois qu'au mieux tout ça il
ya encore une fois une voie médiane
d'abord pour répondre qu'à lire les paul
savary avait raison faut pas brouiller
le message le message aujourd'hui c'est
vigilence vigilence vigilence 458 mort
hier on n'est pas sorti d'affaires il
n'en sortira pas encore tout finit donc
n'allons pas aujourd'hui parce que ça
ira un petit peu mieux j'ai vu que ça
allait mieux en béarn et le pays basque
beaucoup mieux bon tant mieux pour eux
je ne connais pas les raisons fier d'eux
tant mieux pour eux mais on voit bien
que c'est pas le moment de relâcher mais
on peut pas dire aux gens on ne relâche
pas maintenant et ne pas leur dire côté
si on en a six nations on est à huit
millions si je pense vous savez il ya un
phénomène qui m'a surpris c'est pourquoi
en afrique du sud
pourquoi l'afrique du sud d'un seul coup
apparemment été très très inquiétant
c'est retomber brutalement et on à
retomber à nouveau pape
une hypothèse a été fait pareil mais
logique de dire que le virus africain
est peut être beaucoup plus virulent
dans sa transmission
mais qu'en fin de compte comme il est
très violent de la transmission il a
donné peut-être au pays une forme
d'immunité collective prier tout peut
arriver aujourd'hui
donc ce que je crois je sais que je peux
pas dans le même temps dire qu'il faut
pas traiter la formule est uniformément
et dire quand on traite aller
individuellement chaque territoire en
fonction des données épidémiologiques et
de sanitaires acculé on comprend ainsi
qu'il ya une réticence à confiner l'île
de france par habitant
évolué et cetera ce que c'est mais dhabi
- là dessus je dis c'est sur le plan des
responsabilités responsabilité très
lourde que de dire on ne confine pas
beaucoup plus lourd que ça paraît
difficile mme wyss a un appareil de
décisions difficiles une prise de risque
moi je pense que de ce côté là il
fallait la prendre cette prise de risque
1 parce qu'on peut pas tout sacrifier au
détriment de cette épidémie
et n'oublions pas qu'il ya des malades
là qui sont récusés la 1 donc on choisit
entre yves à un déjà donc certes c'est
difficile et donc c'est une décision
très lourde mais effectivement la
facilité sera aussi de dire mon confine
tout pays parce que ya risque trop sur
bénéfice risque ça mérite d'être étudié
de très près avec des différenciations
je suis pas choqué mais elle est on va à
présent rejoint notre streamer politique
jeanjean sur twitter plateforme qu'on ne
présentait plus aucun politique un
aujourd'hui depuis que françois hollande
ya été un lundi et alors quel sujet
d'actualité ont focalisé aujourd'hui
l'attention de tak communauté j'en ai
bien écoute tam aujourd'hui il ya trois
sujets qui intéressent les internautes
qui à la question de la gestion de la
vaccination les internautes se demandent
comme beaucoup de français et je sais
comme beaucoup de sénateurs et
sénatrices pourquoi c'est si lent
pourquoi ça marche pas quand est-ce
qu'on pourra enfin être être vaccinés la
question aussi des mesures de
restriction est ce que le confinement le
week-end ça marche
oui ou non quels sont les résultats dans
le pas de calais par exemple et si
admettons ça montre des chiffres
positifs
va-t-on vers une généralisation dans
d'autres départements par exemple en ile
de france y compris ça c'est des sujets
sur lesquels les internautes attendent
un peu le gouvernement il ya aussi la
question de l'ouverture des lieux
culturels
la réouverture des lieux culturels est
très attendu par par les internautes qui
se demande quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir
retourner au cinéma au théâtre
s'inquiète aussi pour les professionnels
de la culture
et puis la question du pass sanitaires
on en parlait ce qu'on va avoir un qr
code qu'on va pouvoir se lâcher avec son
téléphone pour pouvoir se rendre dans
certains lieux
si oui quelles sont les conditions de
sécurisation des données c'est la
question qui se pose mais pourquoi pas
en fait le sujet fait débat et les
internautes là aussi aimerait bien
entendre les parlementaires saisir le
gouvernement de ce sujet là et le
troisième sujet qui intéresse en ce
moment c'est les rixes entre adolescents
les enfants mineurs qu'ils se battent un
vrai sujet qui est un qui interpelle en
se demandant mais que peut faire en fait
les pouvoirs publics peuvent
les pouvoirs publics peut-on agir et
puis ça pose la question aussi de
l'occupation des adolescents pendant le
pendant le confinement les adolescents
qui peuvent plus aller en centre sportif
qui peuvent plus passer du temps dans
des lieux d'accueil de jeunes des
dispositifs de jeunesse
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres choses
à faire fabriquer ce qu'ils ont d'autre
de mieux à faire que traîner dans la rue
et ça malheureusement ça peut donner des
phénomènes de bandes donc voilà on peut
les sujets si tu veux en ce moment que
les que les internautes attendent pour
cette séance de cet après midi merci
merci beaucoup aux gens à tout à l'heure
pour le débrief écoute tu me fais une
transition parfaite puisque on va
justement abordé et bien cette question
des rixes de jeunes il va y avoir une
question qui va être posée par votre
groupe à rené paul savary sur ce sujet
on va tout de suite rejoindre jean
raymond et gonnet qui est au micro de
steve jourdain parce qu'on essonne il ya
eu pas mal de séries que ça en essonne
en région parisienne l'essonne qui
concentre toutes les inquiétudes se
chiffrent tam en 2020 plus de la moitié
des rixes en ile de france ont eu lieu
dans l'essonne jean raymond legault
n'est question simple c'est quoi le
problème dans l'essonne écoutez je peux
pas dire que
aujourd'hui l'essonne et la plage
l'apanage de la violence malheureusement
l'actualité récente
argenteuil montre que voilà ça ça arrive
partout ce qu'il ya de particulier en
essonne et même si encore une fois ce
n'est pas la panacée universelle
l'essonne manque cruellement depuis 32
ans maintenant d'effectifs de police et
de gendarmerie donc ça concourt
certainement à la difficulté des forces
de l'ordre d'intervenir peut-être en
amont mais on peut pas dire que les
saunas l'apanage c'est un département où
il fait bon vivre
voilà un petit peu la problématique que
je considère quand même que ces luttes
interquartiers font partie en quelque
sorte de l'identité de l'essonne c'est
faux l'identité de l'essonne quand
souvent ces luttes interquartiers ont
lieu dans des villes nouvelles ou dans
des zones très aggloméré au nord du
département
voilà on peut on peut se dire ça
maintenant il y a également en zone
rurale saint chéron qui a été le théâtre
justement du décès de la malheureuse
libel saint chéron on n'est pas dans le
bronx si vous voulez hein on est dans un
endroit charmant et voilà donc ça
s'exporte aussi c'est souvent lié à des
lignes de rer de transport en commun
aussi
voilà c'est un petit peu la spécificité
en essonne l'essonne comporte aussi 30
quartier de reconquête républicaine pour
l'instant c'est un échec cette
reconquête
ah bah écoutez c'est assez patent pour
être ancien président de l'union des
maires de dessins de jeu je suis en
rapport et depuis très longtemps avec
ces mères on voit bien que quand vous
êtes maire de grigny de corbeil d'evry
courcouronnes
pour ne prendre que ces trois communes
je peux vous garantir que c'est un
véritable sacerdoce et c est lui qui
sont des élus de terrain en proximité
immédiats ne reçoivent pas au quotidien
l'aide qui ne devrait recevoir petite
dernière question jean castex doit
diriger une réunion interministérielle
ce vendredi sur ce thème qu'est ce que
vous en attendez écouter à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème
on a des déclarations offusqué on a des
prises de position tout le monde déplore
tout le monde créer un sous groupe de
travail avec voilà moi je ne conteste
pas que jean castex qui est un homme de
terrain et c'est de faire son travail
maintenant bien entendu il faut écouter
il faut surtout entendre et il faut
donner des moyens à ces mères que ce
soit dans la politique de la ville ou
dans les moyens de forces de l'ordre
merci beaucoup j'aurais moins gonnet
d'avoir répondu avec le salon merci
françois patriat votre réaction à cette
violence le phénomène des bandes il a
toujours existé mais on s'interroge face
à cette violence croissante et puis face
aussi et bien en fait que ces jeunes
sont de plus en plus jeune que faut-il
faire face à cette situation
je crois que le phénomène de bande il
existe depuis depuis des dizaines
d'années mais le niveau de violence
une autre société qui sont aujourd'hui
metropolis et avec des villes quartiers
compter des zones de parfois de
l'endroit quand il abandonné ajoutez-y à
côté le problème de la drogue qui touche
les adultes les adolescents un peu plus
âgés se fait même de violence dans la
société il est innée choqué de voir
combien les enfants qui sont les plus
jeunes qui ont des tablettes passe le
temps à s'entretuer à se battre dans le
même temps ni vaincu ou alors elle
évacue partout mais là leur seul jeu
c'est de la violence
moi c'est déjà là je trouve le palais de
l'elysée les joueurs ici des réseaux
sociaux à c'est aussi l'une des grandes
nouveautés via le phénomène aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour les ça c'est pas pour les
plus jeunes malheur donc je pense qu'il
ya eu un plan anti-bandes qui a été mis
en place ce phénomène des bandes ne tape
pas de déduction des manuels mâcon le
soleil chacun est suffisamment ici
intelligent pour le dire mais il ya
aujourd'hui un développement
vous savez c'est toujours un peu l'effet
boule de neige l'effet vitrine l'effet
exemplarité sa rive sud pourquoi nous
nos demandes et terra le ferait d'un
cocktail donc je crois qu'il ya un plan
anti-bandes qui a été mis qui n'est pas
si aujourd'hui efficace il y avait trois
mesures qui avaient été prises
l'année dernière mon 2010 9,3 mesure
avec de l'information de la proximité de
la répression par ailleurs aujourd'hui
le gouvernement a réuni c'est pas des
espaces que disais à l'instant un train
mille sénateurs c'est là aujourd'hui les
quatre ministères concernés un question
nationale
l'intérieur est hélas vite se concertent
pour mettre ensemble leurs moyens à
trois ou quatre niveaux je veux pas les
émeutes du mur est tous un peu long mais
il ya le niveau de la proximité ya le
niveau de l'information ayant le niveau
j'allais dire de la détection et le
niveau de la réponse de là la réponse
peut l'être humain et puis la prévention
a voté il ya quatre niveaux sur lesquels
aujourd'hui les quatre ministères
peuvent se mettre ensemble pour avoir
mieux d'informations plus de
surveillance surveillance des réseaux
sociaux
et puis une répression par une
répression en tout cas une réponse
pénale qui est immédiate
je crois que faire avancer je pense que
ces mesures là elle résoudront pas le
problème des bandes mais ils sont de
notre nature à l'endiguer rené paul
savary est ce que c'est bien ce que nous
indiquions françois patriat en termes de
réponse ministérielle est suffisant face
à ce phénomène est bien sur lequel les
élus à l'ab 2011 en plus à votre groupe
à poser déjà plusieurs questions sur ce
sujet ces dernières sont d'ailleurs si
c'est suffisant et je me suffisent ans
il ya quand même un facteur qu'il faut
soutenir aussi c'est le facteur familial
ya quand même une responsable
parentalité réaction extraordinaire
commun doivent quand même s'inquiéter
l'heure enfin lors ils sont tellement
difficiles ces enfants que les parents
qui baissent les bras qui d'autre les
prêtres mais bon le phénomène est là
nous on était choqués aussi dans le
département de la marne avec votre
collègue journaliste et un caméraman qu
un photographe qu'on connaît depuis des
années et des années qui est encore dans
le coma au bout de jour le jour confer
véritablement scandaleuse par rapport à
la fois aux violences urbaines par
rapport également à la transmission de
l'information quoi donc véritablement
moi je voulais me traduire ma solidarité
vis-à-vis de votre votre confrère lac
est tout à fait essentiel et dire qu'il
faut qu'on se penche davantage aux rôles
de chacun et la famille me semble-t-il
sa rôle essentiel qu'il faut
retravailler redonner du sens à ce thème
famille parce que c'est elle qui met un
peu les bornes nécessaires pour
connaître un peu les limites que doivent
connaître normalement nos enfants voilà
une question sur l'autorité parentale
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir participé à
cette discussion à ce débat est tout de
suite on va retourner salle des
conférences on va rejoindre style
jourdain on va revenir sur une autre
affaire importante celle de lieux paix
de grenoble 2-1 q2 enseignants accusés
publiquement d'islamophobie qui sont
désormais sous protection policière et
steve vous êtes avec le sénateur
socialiste de l'isère andré vallini
andré vallini bonjour bonjour sénateur
de l'isère qu'est ce que cette polémique
autour de l'iep de grenoble vous inspire
je condamne comme tout le monde ce qui
s'est passé à sciences po grenoble la
réprobation la condamnation est unanime
il ne faut pas tomber dans ces
extrémités l'université doit rester le
lieu où l'on peut débattre discuter
s'affrontaient verbalement dans le
respect des uns et des autres les qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ces deux syndicats
donc qui ont relayé ces messages à
l'encontre des deux professeurs qu'est
ce qu'il faut ça ce qu'il faut les
dissoudre est-ce qu'il faut les réformes
et ce qu'il faut ça quelque chose dont
ils ont pris leurs distances
l'unef nationale a pris ses distances
avec ce qui s'est passé à grenoble
moi je suis un ancien étudiant de
sciences po grenoble
à l'époque déjà il y avait des
controverses des débats politiques
violents verbalement violent nous
allions des profs communiste et est
connu comme tel j'avais un professeur
gaulliste qui se présente l âme aux
élections sous l'étiquette du parti
gaulliste de l'époque c'était lui dr
nous avions un professeur illustre
d'histoire de l'union soviétique c'était
pierre broué qui était réputé pour être
trotskiste et puis il y avait des
étudiants de gauche josé partie
étudiants socialistes il y avait des
étudiants communistes et trotskistes il
y avait même des étudiants de droite à
sciences po grenoble
eh bien nous discutions mais c'était
dans le respect je le répète des uns et
des autres l'université c'est le temple
du savoir et du débat de la controverse
des mandats politiques
mais pas le temps de la politique la
politique au sens noble du terme
on s'affronte sur des idées politiques
on ne se désignent pas les uns les
autres à la vindicte populaire
monsieur vallini j'aimerais qu'on parle
aussi de ce projet de loi contre les
séparatismes ce matin dans le figaro
les églises chrétiennes dénoncent un
projet de loi qui entraverait oki
déformerait l'esprit de la loi de 1905
qu'est-ce que
ça vous inspire quelle est votre
réaction je pense qu'il faut écouter ce
que disent les églises j'ai vu comme
vous effectivement que l'église
catholique de lait protestant de france
que les juifs aussi les orthodoxes
s'inquiètent de voir la liberté de culte
remise en cause
je souhaite qu'il n'en soit rien
évidemment et je je je considère que le
sénat va jouer son rôle de sagesse le
sénat est un lieu de sagesse dans la
république pour apaiser les craintes
légitimes par conséquent quels sont les
primes l'état actuel du texte est une
entrave à 1905 est une voie de formation
moi je ne le crois pas je crois que ces
craintes qu'il faut entendre ne sont pas
fondées j'espère que le ministre
monsieur darmanin pourra apporter tous
les apaisements nécessaire pour rassurer
toutes les églises sur le fait que la
liberté de culte et de religion n'est
pas remise en cause en france
merci beaucoup andré vallini répondu à
mes questions merci à steve pour cette
nouvelle réaction et pendant cette
interview on voyait d'ailleurs arrivé
frédéric vidal à la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui va avoir à répondre à une
question autour et bien de cette affaire
de l'irpp et de grenoble la question va
être posée par le sénateur les
républicains un pascal allizard et puis
le style et bien on va vous rejoindre de
nouveau toujours pour continuer à parler
de ce projet de loi sur le séparatisme
vous le disiez en ce projet de loi a
donné lieu à une réaction des églises
notamment églises chrétiennes qui dans
le figaro se disent inquiètes pour leur
liberté et qui dans un appel commun
publié aujourd'hui s'inquiètent des
dérives de ce texte vous allez en parler
et bien avec dominique derrien qui est
sénatrice
us eco rapporteur de ce texte ici au
sénat dominique veryant bonjour vous
avez lu j'imagine cette tribune dans le
figaro aujourd'hui les églises
chrétiennes qui s'inquiètent et bien
d'une déformation de la loi de 1905 la
loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état qu'est ce que vous en penser ce
qu il ya des formations oui ou non de
l'esprit de 1905
sinon je ne pense pas qu'ils aient des
formations de l'esprit de 1905
maintenant je peux entendre des
inquiétudes que nous avons essayé déjà
lors d'auditions de de calme et je crois
que les églises ont quelques attentes
légitimes auxquelles je crois aussi que
le sénat peut répondre mais très
sincèrement non ya pas dévoiement de mon
point de vue de la loi de 1905 et il n'y
a plus de crainte que de réels dangers
je te dise aussi beaucoup de
responsables religieux c'est finalement
toutes les religions vont payer pour les
dérives d'une seule qu'est ce que vous
en pensez que d'abord les dérives d'une
aujourd'hui étaient les dérives d'une
autre hier il faut se dire que 1905 n'a
pas été créé pour les musulmans
d'aujourd'hui elle a été créée pour
l'église catholique que la police des
cultes c'est déjà exercé même si
aujourd'hui on l'a un peu oublié contre
des prêtres que
des mouvements prosélyte il n'y a pas
que les musulmans qui peuvent exister
envoie une église évangélique tous les
neuf jours se crée donc potentiellement
il peut y avoir d'autres sujets
notamment avec les évangéliques quelques
sujets liés à l'éducation contre la
théorie de l'évolution par exemple donc
je crois qu'on ne sait pas de quoi sera
fait demain
la loi 1905 a été créée aujourd'hui elle
s'applique encore ce qui est une bonne
chose c'est important de faire qu'elle
puisse s'appliquer à tous voile question
migratoire question de la liberté dans
ses enseignements
les désaccords entre la droit du sénat
et le gouvernement sont nombreux
pourtant aussi lié ces désaccords
oui alors je pense qu'il ya la droite de
l'assemblée nationale à la droite du
sénat qui n'est pas la même déjà donc je
ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons autant de
différences que ça
personnellement je pense que la droite
sénatoriale et le centre que je
représente sont plutôt favorables à ce
texte quand bien même il faut
effectivement l'aménager merci beaucoup
de militaires d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
oui effectivement aujourd'hui vous venez
de le voir c'est pierre laurent et qui
va présider le sénateur communiste de
paris qui cette semaine remplace jean
lyncher au plateau il s'installe en soi
même le silence se fait dans l'hémicycle
avec je vous le rappelle trois thèmes
principaux aujourd'hui les rixes entre
jeunes de plus en plus jeunes de plus en
plus violentes également et bien la
vaccination on attend trois questions au
total 1 sur la vaccination ou encore les
appels à l'aide du monde de la culture
avec l'occupation de théâtre c'est parti
pour cette séance
tic de la précédente séance a été
distribué y'a pas d'observation le
procès verbal est adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous remercie d'excuser l'absence du
président du sénat pour retenu aux
obsèques d'un ancien sénateur je vous
rappelle que la séance est retransmise
en direct sur public sénat et sur notre
site internet au nom du bureau du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges
l'une des valeurs essentielles du sénat
le respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui du temps
de parole la parole et à notre collègue
hervé marseille pour le groupe union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre les conséquences économiques de
la pandémie pourrait être dévastatrice
et les aides pour l'instant en masquer
l'ampleur
mais lorsque ce sera la perfusion le
choc risque d'être terrible
et rien que dans la restauration on
s'attend d'après les professionnels à
peu près à 30% de faillite
dans ce contexte l'étalement des charges
sur trois ans pour les entreprises
faisant l'objet de fermeture
administrative a bien entendu été
salutaire mais cette mesure certainement
ne suffira pas certaines entreprises
sont restées fermées plus d'un an et la
reprise sera très progressive lorsqu
elles rouvriront leur appliquer à ce
moment là des charges passées en plus
des charges actuel sera le coup de grâce
beaucoup renonceront on voit mal comment
à terme ne pas aller vers des
annulations au moins partielle de charge
ce que vous avez fait en exonérant les
entreprises de charges sociales entre le
1er septembre et le 30 novembre 2020
pour le second confinement à nos yeux ce
dispositif devra inévitablement être
élargie dès avril dernier mon groupe
avait proposé d'annuler les charges des
pme dont le chiffre d'affaires est
inférieur à 50 millions d'euros
ayant subi une perte de chiffre
d'affaires d'au moins 50%
cela afin de cibler la mesure sur les
entreprises les plus affectées et de
limiter son impact sur les finances
publiques
on nous avait dit à l'époque qu'un tel
dispositif serait encore trop lourd pour
le budget de l'état et de la sécurité
sociale nous pouvons l'entendre pour
autant monsieur le premier ministre à
l'occasion d'un dernier comité de
liaison j'avais attiré déjà votre
attention sur ce sujet et vous m'aviez
répondu j'ai ce dossier dans le viseur
alors je serais tenter de vous dire
quand allez vous tirer
tout faux
alors où c'est monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président marseille
merci pour votre question qui me donne
l'occasion de souligner après vous
l'impact extrêmement fort de la crise
sanitaire sur nos acteurs économiques
sur les entreprises sur les salariés sur
les travailleurs indépendants
merci aussi de me donner l'occasion de
rappeler vous l'avez d'ailleurs reconnu
vous même dans votre question que le
gouvernement et le parlement ont déployé
des moyens d'accompagnement extrêmement
massif qui je le crois d'ailleurs en
termes comparatifs sont reconnues comme
telles au bénéfice des entreprises de
leurs salariés des travailleurs
indépendants depuis le début de cette
crise qui dure il ont été vous l'avez
dit monsieur le président à la fois
massif et surtout adapté c'est à dire
qu'au fur et à mesure que nous prenions
des dispositions au fur et à mesure que
le temps passait pour un certain nombre
de secteurs plus encore impacté que
d'autres nous avons su rehausser le
niveau de nos interventions je ne
reviendrai pas sur les pg e sur le fond
de solidarité ou sur les exonérations de
charges qui ont été décidées et qui sont
toujours à l'oeuvre une façon de vous
répondre
monsieur le président c'est que notre
force
avant même de savoir les conditions dans
lesquelles nous pardonnez moi
l'expression des branches seront le
moment venu ces aides est d'avoir la
lucidité politique de les prolonger tant
que la crise dure c'est ce que nous
faisons et nous examinerons notamment
dans le cadre de la conférence du
dialogue social que je réunir est la
semaine prochaine un certain nombre de
ces dispositifs
au regard de la situation économique et
sociale vous m'avez interrogé plus
particulièrement sur la question des
dettes fiscales et sociales des
entreprises
je voudrais rappeler au sénat qu au plan
fiscal
son prêt de 25 milliards d'euros qui
n'ont pas été prélevé auprès des
entreprises qu'il s'agisse de report ou
de remboursements accélérés de créances
que nous avons mis en place des plans de
règlement l'on vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs sur une durée pouvant aller
jusqu'à trois ans qui a été offerte aux
entreprises sur le plan social
de la même façon le soutien et je le dis
historique puisque les entreprises de
moins de 250 salariés des secteurs les
plus touchés ont bénéficié de mesures
d'exonération qui viennent d'exonération
qui ont donc acquis un caractère
définitif
ce sont ainsi près de 8 milliards
d'euros de charges sociales qui ont été
annulés sur la seule année 2000 20 et ce
dispositif ainsi que je l'indiquais il
ya un instant reste actif il ya eu des
reports ensuite c'est sûr que vous
faites allusion des facilités donc de
trésorerie depuis le printemps de
l'année dernière et là on en est quand
même à près de 12 milliards d'euros qui
ont été reportés par les urssaf et qui
ont concerné près de 900 mille
entreprises
et j'ajoute 13 milliards d'euros pour
les travailleurs indépendants les
remboursement de cette dette fiscale et
sociale seront bien entendu premier
principe adapté à la situation de chaque
entreprise pense qu'il nous faut entrer
au delà du d'épanchement qui n'est pas
encore arrivé
je le répète à des mesures au cas par
cas et au total ce sera donc un effort
considérable qui aura été réalisés
permettant vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs de
ne pas déclencher des plans d'apurement
de manière anticipée en obtenant condat
situation des entreprises est en lice
ans au maximum les remboursements de
dettes et c'est cette logique monsieur
présent que nous allons continuer à
adopter
merci monsieur le président marc faye
c'est bien alors la parole est
maintenant
monsieur pierre ouzoulias ce pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre regardez
cet hémicycle un fauteuil sur deux et
laissé libre sous la haute autorité du
président larcher
nous respectons en ce lieu les normes
sanitaires et le sénat n'est pas un
foyer épidémique dans le respect des
mêmes normes
[Applaudissements]
dans le respect des mêmes normes
sanitaires par la vacance d'un fauteuil
sur deux monsieur le premier ministre
quand allez-vous autorisé la réouverture
des salles de cinéma des salles de
spectacles et des sages de cancer
en 2020 votre gouvernement a consacré
près d'un milliard d'euros pour garantir
les droits aux allocations des
intermittents du spectacle cet argent
aura été dépensée en pure perte si votre
gouvernement ne met pas en place
maintenant des aides spécifiques pour
accompagner les artistes dans la reprise
de leurs activités
or votre gouvernement dans le cadre
général d'une réforme de l'assurance
chômage que nous dénonçons a lancé une
mission de réflexion sur le régime de
l'intermittence et a souhaité notamment
que soit étudié sa convergence avec le
régime général tel qu'il sera réformé
pour je cite ne pas générer 10 gagnés
lité supplémentaires entre ceux ci
le monde de la culture avec d'autres a
été durement touchée par la pandémie
les artistes ont besoin d'un fort
soutien de la nation maintenant et
d'être rasées nérée par l'assurance de
la pérennité d'un régime qui garantit
leur existence
monsieur le premier ministre la culture
n'est pas accessoire secondaire ou
subalterne
elle est essentielle car elle constitue
l'essence même de notre nation
monsieur merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs votre question
pierrot zulia se connaissaient bien le
monde de la culture va être l'occasion
pour moi de rappeler quelques points de
contexte premièrement et olivier ferrand
on fera certainement le détail dans
quelques instants la pandémie continue à
toucher durement notre pays et l'europe
deuxième point de contexte les lieux
culturels sont fermés les lieux de
spectacles sont fermés pour 85% des
citoyens européens parce que on mène en
europe une politique de prévention
troisième point de contexte parce que ça
c'est une spécificité de la france dans
aucun pays européen dans aucun pays du
monde
on ne soutient le monde de la culture
comme on le soutient dans notre pays
c'est cela véritablement les éléments de
contexte
alors nous travaillons nous travaillons
à maintenir les droits des intermittents
j'ai confié nous avons confié avec la
ministre du travail d'une mission à
monsieur goron qui rendra dans quelques
jours ses conclusions en aucune façon
nous ne reviendrons sur les droits des
intermittents nous les protégerons ça
c'est absolument absolument
indispensable et nous travaillons même
pour améliorer le dispositif en
particulier avec les primo entrants
parce qu'il faut protéger nos jeunes nos
jeunes dans la culture mais nous aurons
s'il ya une réunion de match et le
premier ministre nous aurons aussi des
annonces substantielle à faire pour ce
monde de la culture que nous voulons
protéger en tout cas je veux dire une
chose très importante c'est que
l'occupation des lieux de culture n'est
pas le bon moyen cette inutile car les
difficultés du monde de la culture nous
les connaissons mais ces manoeuvres sont
dangereuses elles sont dangereuses car
elles mettent en menace des lieux
patrimoniaux fragile nous avons besoin
de travailler avec les artistes nous les
protégeons et nous continuerons à les
protéger
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue xavier iacovelli pour le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes indépendante monsieur le
président messieurs ministre nombre de
nos concitoyens doivent renoncer à se
soigner et sont ainsi privés de la
possibilité de voir où d'entendre
correctement parfois même de sourire
ces difficultés d'accès aux soins
entraîne à chaque fois des drames
individuels rappelé le président de la
république lors du 42e congrès de la
mutualité française lorsque les français
faute de moyens renonce à une nouvelle
paire de lunettes ou un appareil auditif
c'est notre pacte social qui est abîmée
c'est pourquoi dès 2019 le gouvernement
a mis en place la réforme du 100% santé
après les soins dentaires et l'optique
l'an dernier les aides auditives sont
désormais prises en charge à 100 %
depuis le 1er janvier 2021 permettent
aux français et notamment les plus
fragiles d'accéder à des soins de
qualité c'est donc toute l'ambition de
cette réforme de justice sociale nous en
avons désormais la certitude
cette réforme porte ses fruits demain
jeudi 11 mars paraîtra une étude harris
interactive pour ufc que choisir et le
réseau santéclair démontrant que 50% des
ventes d'appareils auditifs en janvier
et en février de cette année ont été
réalisés sur des offres sans reste à
charge
cette réforme bénéficie à tous aux
français bien sûr en premier lieu mais
aussi aux assureurs ou mutuelles et aux
professionnels
c'est tout en préservant la claque là
car tout en préservant la clientèle
existante
un nouveau public accède désormais à des
produits sans reste à charge
le président de la république depuis le
début de la crise fait du made in france
en matière de santé une priorité absolue
il s'agit de soutenir davantage nos pme
françaises mais également de faciliter
les approvisionnements et de les rendre
plus responsables il s'agit aussi de
défendre notre souveraineté sanitaire
qui passera par un soutien à la
production française de ces dispositifs
médicaux qui sont désormais parfois le
quotidien des français la création d'un
label visant à mieux informer nos
concitoyens et à les éclairer dans leurs
choix constituerez à cet égard une prise
de réflexion intéressantes ma question
monsieur le
str elle arrive à larry vous inquiétez
pas je sais que ça vous dérange mais
monsieur le ministre comment rendre
cette réforme plus lisible pour que les
français s'en saisissent pleinement tout
en favorisant la production française et
en soutenant nos pme monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
mesdames mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur iacovelli
vous posez vous poser une question sur
un sujet qui est absolument fondamental
pour notre pays
pourquoi un sujet fondamental parce
qu'il se trouve à la croisée des chemins
entre le sanitaire et les solidarités
cette réforme le 100% santé qui est il
mis en place par ma prédécesseure à
l'initiative du président la république
il s'y était engagée dans son programme
et il l'a tenu son engagement
cette réforme est rentrée en plein
exercice à partir du 1er janvier de
l'année 2021 et cela fait maintenant
deux ans que progressivement et se met
en place avec des résultats qui sont
spectaculaires spectaculaire d'abord
vous dire que le renoncement aux soins
pour raisons financières dans notre pays
c'était 10 % des français dans l'optique
c'était 17% dans le domaine du dentaire
et il n'y avait que 35 % des personnes
qui se faisait prescrire une
audioprothèses pour bien entendre qu'ils
allaient faire cette démarche de
s'équiper l'audioprothèse il y avait
donc là un objet un objectif majeur qui
était de lutter contre le renoncement
aux soins d'abord nous avons plafonner
les tarifs des prothèses ensuite nous
avons mis en place un début d'autres
100% santé en vigueur au 1er janvier
2020 et puis depuis le 1er janvier 2021
le panier dentaire 100% santé a été
élargie à 57 nouvelles prothèses et
l'offre en audiologie désormais
garantissant reste à charge à dire que
concrètement une aide auditive en 2018
ça coûtait 1700 euros de reste à charge
pour un français en 2020 c'était 800
euros de rsa charge pour un français en
c'est zéro euro de restes à charge pour
tous les français qui participent et qui
profitent de cette offre vous en avez
parlé de résultats sont déjà au rendez
vous malgré la crise sanitaire
48% des prothèses posées entre janvier
et septembre 2020 et prothèses dentaires
correspondent au panier 100% santé sans
reste à charge pour les français c'est
une offre avec un contenu de qualité
vous parliez par exemple des entreprises
françaises oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya
des offres de deux prothèses d'origine
française pour les verts par exemple ce
sont des verres anti rayures anti reflet
des verts amincie il s'agit absolument
pas de matériel low cost ou à bas coût
au rabais d'ailleurs les français qui ne
s'y trompe pas qui sont très nombreux à
bénéficier de ce 100 % santé je vous dis
ma conviction
demain ils seront encore plus nombreux
et même bien plus nombreux et dans
quelques années dans quelques mois
peut-être nous aurons oublié ce que
c'était que le renoncement aux soins
pour bien voir bien manger bien entendre
et bien parlé merci merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue annie le houérou pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
monsieur le premier ministre lundi 8
mars journée internationale des droits
des femmes
il y à 110 ans en mars 1911 clara z king
et l'internationale socialiste des
femmes célèbres cette première journée
elle revendique la fin des
discriminations au travail en 2021 nous
vivons encore dans cette société
française où les inégalités liées au
travail sont bien réels l'écart salarial
brut entre les hommes et les femmes est
de 28% alors de la retraite les femmes
personnes perçoivent en moyenne une
pension inférieure de 41% à celle des
hommes tristes résultats des inégalités
professionnelles et des carrières
précarisés des femmes
il s'explique par les temps partiels
subis les familles monoparentales à 80%
porté par les femmes l'accès réduit aux
postes d'encadrement la crise du coc
vide a révélé avec force inégalités
elles sont en première ligne pour nous
soigner 97 % des infirmières 87% des
aides soignantes
elles sont en première ligne pour
prendre soin de nos aînés et des
personnes vulnérables
97 % des aides à domicile sont des
femmes elles sont majoritaires dans les
métiers de l'éducation de la grande
distribution dans le secteur de la
propreté métiers dits essentiels
revalorisons ses métiers et nous ferons
coup double nous réduirons l'écart des
rémunérations et nous sortirons des
préjugés et des stéréotypes existant sur
ces métiers en tension qui intéresse
aussi les hommes
vous avez fait un premier pas avec de
ségur de la santé en revalorisant les
professionnels de santé
rattaché aux hôpitaux mais en excluant
par exemple sages-femmes et tout le
champ du social et du médico social dont
les aides à domicile
monsieur le premier ministre les
premières de corvée sont elles les
oublier
premier de cordée qui forment le cabinet
présidentiel êtes vous prêt à
revaloriser ces métiers du social et du
médico-social qui représente plus de un
million de salariés dont 175 mille
postes à pourvoir à l'échelle d'ici 2025
donner les moyens aux gestionnaires de
ce secteur
quel que soit leur statut de relever ce
défi merci chers collègues la parole à
madame elisabeth morano ministre
déléguée chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité et
de l'égalité des chances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice annie le houérou
les chiffres que vous venez de partager
sont édifiants et j'aimerais y ajouter
que dans notre pays
pays les droits de l'homme et de la
femme en 2021
nous n'avons que 2 % des entreprises qui
atteignent la parité parfaite
aujourd'hui nous avons encore 13 % de
nos entreprises qui ne rémunère pas ou
qu'ils n'augmentent pas le salaire des
femmes qui rendent de congé maternité
alors même que c'est une obligation
et vous me direz il est encore plus
urgent d'agir parce que je suis
convaincu que l'émancipation des femmes
passera aussi par leur indépendance
économique et c'est pour ça que notre
gouvernement agit
vous avez mentionné le ségur c'est une
étape extrêmement importante mais il
faut la compléter et nous l'avons
compléter avec l'index égalité
professionnelle qui nous positionne la
france aujourd'hui au niveau mondial
comme l'un des pays qui travaillent le
plus sur l'égalité salariale pour les
hommes et les femmes au niveau européen
mais aussi au niveau mondial mais il ne
faut pas nous arrêter là au delà de la
création de cet index
nous avons également créé le congé
paternité nous en avons longtemps parlé
dans notre pays ce gouvernement-là mis
en place parce que je crois aussi que
l'émancipation économique des femmes et
le fait qu'il y ait une meilleure
répartition dans les foyers des tâches
feront que les femmes se sentiront plus
libres pour avancer dans leurs
et puis il ya également la lutte contre
la précarité parce que l'émancipation
économique des femmes
c'est aussi lutter contre les précarités
qui touche souvent les familles
monoparentales et 85 % des familles
monoparentales sont portés par des
femmes et c'est pour ça que nous avons
créé le ce nouveau service public qui
permet aux femmes de toucher les
pensions alimentaires directement par
les caisses d'allocations familiales
parce que quand elle souffre de 20% de
budget en moins
c'est extrêmement difficile et puis la
reconnaissance que vous avez mentionné
des travailleurs de la deuxième ligne
elisabeth bornes mène en ce moment a
encore en concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux une revalorisation
des métiers dits de la deuxième ligne
les hôtes et les hôtesses de caisse les
éboueurs les agents d'entretien les
aides à domicile qui sont tous mobilisés
de manière exceptionnelle durant cette
pandémie
en conclusion madame la sénatrice mme
puri tonique faut conclure réaliser
cette égalité économique entre les
femmes et les hommes nous devons mener
des politiques très volontariste une
proposition de loi a été déposé à
l'assemblée nationale et je m'en réjouis
et le chemin vers l'égalité est encore
long mais je suis à votre disposition et
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner le
travail exceptionnel que votre
délégation fait sur ce sujet merci bien
la parole est maintenant à henri cabanel
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres cher collègue
monsieur le ministre le message envoyé
le dimanche 7 mars par la direction
générale de la santé à propos de
l'interruption des livraisons de vaccins
pour une semaine aux généralistes au
profit des officines à susciter la
stupéfaction des médecins et de leurs
patients mais aussi des pharmaciens les
personnes qui devaient être vaccinés la
semaine prochaine les cabinets voient
donc leur rendez vous annulé sa même
savoir si les pharmaciens prendront le
relais à vouloir multiplier les
vaccinations les vaccinateurs pardon
sans coordination en eux multiplient ni
les vaccins ni les vacciner les enjeux
définis sur la santé publique et son
efficacité multiplier les acteurs et les
centres de vaccination est évidemment un
objectif louable
incontestablement la vaccination s'est
accélérée c'est un point fort il est
important de stabiliser l'organisation
en place pour monter en puissance
ensuite les professionnels et les
citoyens ne comprennent plus ses
changements de cap il ya un réel
problème de méthode dans la gestion de
cette crise sanitaire
l'idée n'est pas de critiquer pour
critiquer l'idée est de comprendre les
décisions pour acquérir une
acceptabilité pourquoi ne pas penser une
organisation territoriale comme vous
l'avez fait pour les confinements avait
l'appui des élus locaux en permettant
aux pharmaciens de pouvoir vacciner tout
comme les infirmiers les sages de femmes
dans les territoires des pauvres de
médecins ou lorsqu'il n'y a pas assez de
médecins volontaires mais pas à la place
2 cette décision va démobiliser les
médecins engagés qui ont fait acte de
citoyenneté à se mobiliser à vos côtés
pour accélérer la vaccination
pouvez vous expliquer les motivations
qui vous ont conduit à prendre cette
décision
merci chers collègues la parole à
olivier vers hominidés solidarité de la
santé
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur henri
cabanel merci pour votre question parce
que je voudrais clarifier les choses
parce qu'à la lecture de votre question
je me dis que les choses ne sont pas
encore suffisamment clarifier et c'est
vrai que on peut dire que sur la forme
un communiqué en fin de document
important de quelques lignes envoyez le
soir du dimanche a pu créer l'émoi et je
le comprends monsieur le sénateur il ya
une chose fondamentale que vous avez dit
sur laquelle je voudrais revenir tout de
suite quand vous dites que les
vaccinations organisée par les médecins
libéraux dans ce pays doivent être
annulées pour la semaine prochaine
je vous le dis tout de suite et sans
aucune hésitation c'est faux monsieur le
sénateur la totalité la totalité des
doses de vaccin commandées par les
médecins généralistes qui arrive cette
semaine c'est à dire les 765 mille doses
que les milliers de médecins ont
recommandé la semaine dernière leur
seront fournis à partir de jeudi et
vendredi
et donc pourront être utilisés pour
vacciner leurs malades comme cela était
prévu la semaine prochaine
je lève je lève cette ambigüité parce
que s'il vous plaît j'ai comme beaucoup
d'entre vous des remontées de médecins
qui ça qui s'alarment en disant on aura
donc pas de nom ce qui a été dit au
médecin c'est que la semaine suivante
les livraisons par le laboratoire
astrazeneca ont été réduites je le dis
et je le déplore comme peau de chagrin
au lieu et place et 765 mille doses que
nous avons donc livré sur notre
territoire cette semaine il y aura la
semaine prochaine quelques 260 280 mille
doses seulement deux vaccins livrés et
donc nous avons dit aux médecins qu'ils
sont nombreux à être volontaire et que
nous n'avons pas assez de vaccins pour
leur fournir des doses
en conséquence la semaine suivante est
donc cette semaine ils vont chercher
leur dos comme prévu il vaccine la
semaine prochaine par contre ils ne
peuvent pas commandé pour la semaine
prochaine parce que nous n'avons pas ces
doses par ailleurs et l'abs et messieurs
les sénateurs vous y serez sensible
je remercie les médecins libéraux qui
sont très nombreux à se mobiliser pour
vacciner mais la moitié d'entre eux n'a
pas encore passé de commandes et donc la
moitié des français de ce pays ne peut
toujours pas se faire vacciner dans son
cabinet de ville nous avons donc
considéré qu'en plus des médecins il
fallait permettre aux pharmaciens de
commencer à vacciner
pour permettre à tous les patients sur
tout le territoire national de
bénéficier des pharmaciens sur les 20000
existant qui en l'espace de deux jours
se sont portés volontaires
c'est une bonne nouvelle il ya de la
place pour tout le monde mais n'a pesé
messieurs les sénateurs
évidemment pour les médecins que je
remercie pour leur engagement leur
cabinet il faut compter sur mon
engagement
il n'y aurait pas de sens à les priver
cette vaccination ils ont 1,2 million de
doses encore à l'actionner ils le feront
et je les en remercie
il ya un merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et à d'autres collègues
esther benbassa ap arnaud excusez moi
excusez moi monsieur cabanel ils vont s
24 secondes
merci monsieur le prix d'un monsieur le
ministre alors c'est un problème de
communication parce que les médecins ont
bien compris ce que j'avais dit
apparemment ils ne vous ont pas compris
à vous je reviens sur la méthode il faut
arrêter d'infantiliser les français
c'est l'explication d un jeu ils ne
peuvent pas comprendre les mesures
comment comprendre qu'ils peuvent aller
par exemple en espagne ou en italie y
manger au restaurant quand en france ils
sont fermés depuis six mois
comment comprendre qu'ils peuvent
prendre le métro le rer le tgv et
l'avion mais qu'il ne peut pas aller au
cinéma et au théâtre
merci chers collègues et encore toutes
mes excuses
la parole donc à esther benbassa pour le
groupe confie solidarité territoire
monsieur le ministre
dès 2014 la chine accuse les ouïghours
minorité musulmane de chine yang de
radicalisme politique et religieux etc
ont fui des camps dits de rééducation
pour les y enfermer de manière
préventive
entre un et trois millions sont déportés
albi tellement dans ces camps de
concentration et de travail
les enfants sont éloignés de leurs
parents les couples séparés
les détenus doivent renoncer à leur
langue et leur religion
on pratique stérilisation et avortements
forcés les tortures et les viols
sans le long du quotidien l'objectif des
autorités chinoises
et d'éradiquer l'identité ouïghoure le
17 décembre dernier le parlement
européen a adopté une résolution visant
à sanctionner les responsables chinois à
l'origine de ce nettoyage ethnique vous
même monsieur le ministre en février
vous avez dénoncé je vous cite un
système de répression institutionnalisée
devant le conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'onu selon une étude australienne
des dizaines de milliers de ouïghours
ont été transférés dans des usines
appartenant à 83 grandes marques
internationales où ils sont en situation
d' esclavage y allons au conseil de
paris le groupe écologiste déposé un
voeu relatives à l' oppression d une
good
aujourd'hui c'est le groupe écologiste
du sénat qui vous demandent disait on et
d'autres membres de l'union européen de
votre pouvoir de pression économique au
diplomatique si puissante que puis
semblait la chine
que comptez-vous faire devront nous dire
demain que nous ne savions pas où que
nous ne pouvions rien
merci chers collègues la parole à jean
yves le drian mini de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères oui madame madame la
sénatrice
vous avez évoqué avec justesse les
pratiques injustifiable qui se déroule
au chignon l'effet que vous évoquez les
stérilisations forcées les abus sexuels
dans les camps les disparitions les
détentions massive le travail forcé la
destruction du patrimoine culturel
à commencer par les lieux de culte la
mise sous surveillance de la population
tout cela est attesté et c'est la raison
pour laquelle au nom de la france devant
le conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies vous avez bien voulu le
rappeler
j'ai évoqué il ya quelques jours le fait
qu'il s'agissait d'un système de
surveillance et de répression
institutionnalisé à grande échelle les
10 ha devant les nations unies je le
redis ici devant le sénat c'était il ya
quelques jours je voudrais ici réitérer
mon appel insistant pour qu'une mission
impartiale indépendante et transparente
d'experts internationaux puissent se
rendent dans le xinjiang le plus vite
possible sous la responsabilité de la
haute commissaire aux droits de l'homme
madame bachelet je voudrais aussi redire
ici la responsabilité des entreprises
françaises pour qu'elles exercent la
plus grande vigilance y compris en tant
que société mère sur les risques liés à
la chaîne de valeur et la nécessité de
prévenir des atteintes graves aux droits
fondamentaux auprès des ouïghours
c'est indispensable j'aurais aussi vous
dire que nous avons oeuvré pour que lors
de l'accord sur les investissements
entre l'union européenne et la chine
l'obligation de souscrire à la
convention de l'organisation
internationale du travail sur le travail
forcé a été mise sur la table par la
france et qu'on entend bien la faire
respecter
et enfin madame la sénatrice nous
travaillons aujourd'hui avec nos
collègues européens pour avoir une
position commune après avoir documenté
les faits les expertiser et prendre en
conséquence les initiatives que nous
devons prendre et que vous avez en
partie évoqué à la suite du vote du
parlement européen
un merci monsieur le ministre la parole
à notre collègue emmanuel capus pour le
groupe les indépendants merci monsieur
le président j'entends parfois certains
s'inquiétaient du développement de la 5g
dans les grandes villes mais pour être
tout à fait honnête monsieur le ministre
j'entends plus souvent des mères et des
citoyens réclamé une meilleure
couverture internet dans nos territoires
partout dans nos campagnes sur le bord
de nos routes
nous voyons des poteaux abîmé et des
lignes téléphoniques à même le sol les
élus locaux sont démunis face à cette
dégradation du réseau
bien sûr je sais que le plan très haut
débit or que l'ambition d'un
développement rapide de la fibre et la
fibre va progressivement remplacer le
réseau cuivre
mais d'ici là monsieur le ministre il
faut composer avec l'existant et
l'existant pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens pour beaucoup d'eux mêmes
c'est le seul moyen le plus simple c'est
le réseau cuivre
c'est le principal moyen de connexion à
internet pour nos concitoyens
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
concerne donc la maintenance de ce
réseau de nombreux élus locaux n'ont
pour monter des situations déplorables
voire dangereuse des situations qui
atteste d'un manque d'entretien du
réseau en zone rurale et j'imagine qu'en
ardèche c'est la même chose en
maine-et-loire
comme dans les eaux d'anjou par exemple
il a fallu la mobilisation des élus
locaux pour que l'opérateur
entretiennent bien le réseau monsieur le
ministre
avez vous dressé un état des lieux de la
situation quel suivi comptez-vous mettre
en oeuvre pour garantir la maintenance
du réseau cuivre jusqu'à sa disparition
complète
il ya merci la parole à monsieur olivier
du soap ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'appui vous l'avez dit
beaucoup d'élus mais au delà des élus
beaucoup de nos concitoyens s'inquiètent
de la maintenance du réseau cuivre pour
la téléphonie
il s'agit de françaises et français qui
vivent soit dans des zones mal couvertes
aujourd'hui par la téléphonie mobile ou
qui par habitude par manque d'habitude
plus exactement ne pratique ni à
téléphonie mobile ni l'accès à internet
ce réseau cuivre comme nous l'appelons
doit disparaître et doit s'éteindre en
2030 pour être remplacé par un réseau
fibre mais d'ici là il est essentiel
d'assurer son entretien et nous avons
tous vécu toutes et tous pu constater et
notamment dans les départements ruraux
des difficultés à l'entretien du réseau
par l'opérateur historique des
difficultés qui sont liées aussi à des
délais de réparation sont parfois
extrêmement long en particulier après
des épisodes climatiques au des
incidents qui met à mal le réseau et les
poteaux vous avez rappelé dont on voit
parfois le traîneau les états c'est un
sujet dont il nous faut nous saisir la
transition vers le réseau fibre que j'ai
évoqué la transition vers le haut débit
est une nécessité mais l'entretien et le
bon fonctionnement du réseau cuivre est
une condition essentielle à sa réussite
nous travaillons actuellement avec les
opérateurs bien évidemment avec l'arcep
pour rétablir à la fois une cartographie
un plan d'action nous nous appuyons
aussi sur les travaux récents qui ont
été confiées à la député de la drôme
madame célia de la vergne qui a mené une
mission au nom l'assemblée nationale
mission dont les résultats ont été
rendus le 10 février dernier
d'ici la fin du mois de mars cedrico
notre collègue secrétaire d'état aura
l'occasion avec les principaux
opérateurs d'annoncer un plan d'action
qui permettra à la fois de préciser sur
la base une cartographie des zones les
plus à même les plus endommagés comment
les réparations doivent être aidés
comment le réseau doit être entretenue
qui permettra aussi posé les bases du
futur service public universel
c'est intérieur le haut débit et qui
fixera un calendrier et une carte de
déploiement des travaux pour assurer cet
entretien et l'accès à un réseau cuivre
de qualité cela ne doit pas nous
empêcher de continuer à travailler tout
particulièrement dans le plan de relance
sur le déploiement du très haut débit
nous avons prévu des crédits
supplémentaires à la fois
les réseaux de fibre optique mais aussi
pour le déploiement de nouveaux pilotes
de façon à permettre un accès partout et
dans de bonnes conditions à une solution
de téléphonie qui sont accessibles à
toutes et à tous merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur qu'a pu vous avez 25
secondes
oui merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse vous l'avez compris vous
l'avez dit ce sont particulièrement dans
cette période sanitaire spéciale les
territoires les plus isolées les
personnes les femmes et les hommes les
plus fragiles qui se retrouve doublement
isolée et ce d'autant plus que nos
services publics sont de plus en plus
numérisé et donc il est extrêmement
important
comme vous l'avait dit pour les dix
prochaines années avant la disparition
totale du réseau cuivre d'avoir un
entretien effectif
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à pascal allizard pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis plusieurs
semaines la france est rattrapé par des
polémiques à propos d'événements à mon
sens inquiétant survenus dans
l'enseignement et sort de la can seule
culture orientations politiques des
recherches recul de la laïcité mise en
cause des professeurs cet appareil c'est
à grenoble c'est ailleurs le débat se
focalise sur l'influencé que peut avoir
la convergence de l'islamisme radical et
de l'extrême gauche je cite que certains
qualifient d' islam au gauchisme sur la
vie quotidienne et les études dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
la simple utilisation de ce vocabulaire
d'islam au gauchisme pour décrire même
imparfaitement un phénomène réel vous
expose déjà madame la ministre à des
procès en sorcellerie
vous avez pris le parti et c'est
courageux de vous saisir du problème et
commander un bilan de la recherche
demande aussitôt qualifié par des
chercheurs et syndicats de menaces de
répression intellectuelle
je note qu'une partie de l'exécutif a
pris ses distances avec votre initiative
évoquant l' attachement absolu du
président à l'indépendance des
enseignants-chercheurs
alors ma question est simple peut-on
faire du en même temps sur ces sujets
graves
quelle est la véritable doctrine du
gouvernement en la matière et d'ailleurs
il y en at il une
la parole la parole à madame crédit
really la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation
non mesdames et messieurs c'est un
monsieur sénateurs allizard les
événements les faits les polémiques que
vous mentionnez d'appel qu'une réponse
et c'est évidemment une réponse commune
à l'ensemble du gouvernement comme au
président de la république
notre priorité est et sera toujours la
même sur ces sujets protéger les
personnels garantir la liberté
académique et la pluralité des sujets de
recherche
évidemment dans le respect des lois et
cela pour tous
chacun doit pouvoir exercer librement sa
mission de recherche et d'enseignement
choisir librement ses sujets de
recherche mais toute tentative de
pression d'intimidation de menaces
d'injures qu'elle vienne de l'intérieur
ou de l'extérieur doivent être condamnés
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons admettre
ce qui s'est produit sur les murs de
l'épée de grenoble ou sur les réseaux
sociaux
vous m'avez entendu ici toujours
défendre la liberté de la recherche lors
du débat en deuxième lecture sur la loi
de bioéthique ou lors des débats sur la
loi de recherche
je n'ai jamais dit autre chose
l'inspection que j'ai sollicités à
grenoble permettra j'en suis sûr
d'identifier toutes les responsabilités
de rétablir la sérénité je le ferai
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire
l'université est et doit rester le lieu
des débats parfois vifs parfois
contradictoires nous reconnaître et la
formule toujours respectueux débattre
ces différentes de s'opposer stérilement
débattre c'est bien la vocation de
l'université la violence verbale encore
moins que la violence physique n'y ont
pas leur place
et ça aussi vous m'avez toujours entendu
le dire alors oui quelle proportion de
colloques annulé quelle quantité
d'universitaires empêcher qu'elles réel
pluralité sur les sujets de recherche
c'est comme cela que nous préserverons
la liberté académique de tous et pour
moi c'est essentiel
monsieur ali l'art vous avez 40 secondes
l'enseignement je le crois et je pense
que nous en sommes tous convaincus est
et doit rester le creuset de la
république et de la nation et on ne peut
pas accepter sans réagir
qu'il devienne l'incubateur du
séparatisme et d'ivoire des enseignants
placés sous protection policière
la laïcité c'est bien la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire c'est aussi
cantonner la religion quelle qu'elle
soit à la sphère privée est en tout cas
jamais au dessus des lois de la
république
un nombre élevé de lycéens c'est l'étude
de la licra juge que les textes relatifs
à la laïcité sont discriminatoires
envers les musulmans
on mesure bien les effets concrets et
délétère de tous ces discours sur des
citoyens en devenir
c'est très inquiétant pour l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
puis la parole la parole est maintenant
madame christine lagarde pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci de son président la semaine
dernière mon collègue jean françois
husson interrogé le gouvernement sur les
délais de remboursement partiel des
matches achetés par les collectivités
force est de constater que dans mon
département 25 % des communes sont
toujours en attente
je vais nous donner l'occasion cet
après-midi d'essayer d'anticiper sur le
remboursement des charges liées aux
centres de vaccination alors dans mon
département la rs a envoyé un
questionnaire aux collectivités leur
indiquant qu'ils étaient désormais
opérationnels pour mettre en place le
conventionnement et que ce
conventionnement permettra un
cofinancement sur la base d'un
cofinancement je me suis intéressé
ensuite au montant de ce conte
financement j'ai trouvé une circulaire
de la direction générale de la santé qui
parle d'un montant de 50 mille euros
pour six mois
alors monsieur le ministre je vais avoir
deux questions très simples
quelles vont être les modalités de ce
remboursement les 50000 euros me
semblant complètement déconnecté de la
réalité des coûts supportés la
collectivité et dans quel délai la
parole à monsieur olivier viron mini des
solidarités de la santé
madame madame la sénatrice merci pour
votre question d'abord en profiter pour
remercier l'ensemble des élus qui sont
mobilisés nous l'avons vu que le premier
ministre ce week-end avec le ministre de
l'intérieur aussi dans son département
les centres de vaccination se sont
montés en france dans notre pays à une
vitesse remarquable avec une efficacité
redoutable au bon sens du terme et dans
chaque centre où je vais je rencontre
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
sénateurs et sénatrices de tous bords le
constat est unanime
ça fonctionne bien ah oui ça fonctionne
bien ça fonctionne bien grâce à la
mobilisation de tous les agences
régionales de santé des préfets des élus
des agents des collectivités
territoriales des médecins des
pharmaciens et les infirmiers et
sages-femmes des retraités des étudiants
et ça il faut pouvoir le dire ensuite la
formule consacrée vous la connaissez
quoi qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte donc cette formule
elle s'applique aussi au fonctionnement
des centres nous adapterons le soutien
financier aux municipalités de manière à
les accompagner dans la durée et encore
plus dans la phase d'accélération de la
vaccination
l'assurance-maladie madame la sénatrice
pour être factuel prend déjà directement
en charge la plupart des dépenses je
pense aux paiements directs et des
professionnels aux paiements directs des
établissements qui sont déjà référencés
mais comme les médecins en activité ou
les hôpitaux
les professionnels de santé à la
retraite sont aussi pris en charge dans
ce cadre en lien avec la structure à
laquelle ils sont rattachés ce sont donc
bien l'assurance maladie qui paye les
effecteurs c'est tout à fait normal
bon ce qui peut pas être soumis
directement à la prise en charge par
l'assurance maladie notamment les
fonctionnements généraux des centres
nous avons délégué dès le 18 février 60
millions d'euros aux agences régionales
de santé sur lui ce qu'on appelle le
firent le fonds d'intervention régional
pour permettre de financer les dépenses
les plus urgentes des 1300 centre ouvert
sur tout le territoire national
nous travaillons à l'élargissement et à
l'assouplissement du financement que
nous apportons aux structures qui ne
sont pas encore labellisé ses 60
millions d'euros c'est pas pour solde de
tout compte madame la sénatrice c'est
une amorce important ce sont des fonds
qui seront ré abondé autant que
nécessaire le financement des centres ne
ce n'est pas et ne sera pas et ne devra
pas être en aucun moment un facteur
bloquant dans la campagne vaccination
que tout le monde
livres
courage sur tout le territoire national
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre madame lagarde vous avez plus
d'une minute
9 oui alors merci beaucoup j'ai été très
attentive au fait que l'ensemble des
coûts de ce que je crois comprendre
c'est en tout cas une large partie
serait compensée par des crédits
délégués par l'état elle aurait
peut-être falloir faire mieux que pour
les masques parce que aujourd'hui dans
mon département on me répond que si un
quart des communes ne sont toujours pas
remboursé c'est parce que l'état n'a pas
assez de crédit certaines dépenses ont
été exposés au mois de juillet donc sur
les centres de vaccination nous avons
des coûts qui sont très élevées très
supérieur aux 50000 euros prévus dans la
note d'hôtel la dgs qui finalement vient
mobiliser ce fonds d'intervention
régional je vais vous donner quelques
exemples
la ville de boulogne billancourt 985
1000 euros sur six mois la ville
d'asnières 457000 euros
la ville de clichy 714 1000 euros et
j'ai pas pu faire toute la france mais
j'ai été interrogé j'ai été interrogé
des maires dans des communes par exemple
en meurthe et moselle
la ville de saint max elle ne savait
même pas qu'elle pourrait avoir le droit
à un soutien de la rs quand helm a
énuméré la liste des mises à disposition
aussi bien de locaux que de personnel on
dépassera ce long temps de 50000 euros
sur six mois aujourd'hui les
collectivités vous savez elles ne
peuvent pas à présenter un
fonctionnement déficitaires alors
peut-être regarder ce qui avait été fait
dans le cadre de la grippe h1n1
on avait un bien duvauroux différencié
pour les différents postes
l'anssi
là
la parole la parole est à d'autres
collègues olivier jacquin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre du travail
vous avez indiqué récemment être une
femme de gauche avec la justice sociale
chevillée au corps
je vous interroge donc sur les
conditions de travail des travailleurs
des plates formes particulièrement dans
le domaine des transports en 2018 2019
par deux fois le conseil constitutionnel
a censuré vos charte facultative à
l'initiative du groupe parlementaire
socialiste le 4 mars 2020 et la cour de
cassation a requalifié un chauffeur über
en salariés qualifiant cette situation
d' indépendance fictive le 30 novembre
2020 dont le rapport fruit un que vous
avez commandé a enterré l'idée d'un
tiers statut pendant ce temps les
conditions de ces travailleurs se sont
particulièrement dégradées avec une
explosion des pratiques illégales de
certaines plateformes
un syndicat de chauffeurs de vtc y nv
vous alerter régulièrement ils ont même
saisi un avocat maître juil ch'ti qui
vous a écrit en octobre vous demandant
de saisir l'inspection du travail et de
contrôle et hubert devant votre silence
la semaine dernière 168 chauffeur de vtc
ont saisi le tribunal administratif afin
que la justice vous contraignent à
saisir l'inspection du travail
mais où est l'état de droit madame la
ministre
allez vous enfin saisir l'inspection du
travail pour protéger ses travailleurs
plutôt que les plateformes
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur laurent pietra chef qui
secrétaire d'état chargé des retraites
et de la santé au travail
merci monsieur le président mon show
sénateur jacques 1 c'est vrai que je
connais votre intérêt et la qualité de
votre travail sur le sujet et des
plateformes et plus globalement des
relations entre les plateformes et les
travailleurs qui contribuent à cette
activité
c'est à dire un sujet complexe vous avez
vous même site et à un certain nombre de
décisions de justice nous aussi on
reconnaissait le de rapports qui ont pu
être demandée et qui ont contribué au
débat et à avancer sur ce sujet alors
oui monsieur le sénateur il faut réguler
en tenant compte du fait que la grande
majorité quand même de ces travailleurs
ont fait le choix de l'indépendance mais
aussi mais aussi parce qu'il est
indéniable que la relation est trop
déséquilibré alors il était essentiel
que ces acteurs se retrouvent et puis ce
dans le cadre d'un dialogue social
structuré pouvoir trouver les voies de
sortie
je crois que vous appelez vous aussi de
vos jours la matière c'est la raison
pour laquelle la ministre du travail que
vous avez cité à de nombreuses reprises
dans votre question a nommé trois
personnes qualifiées pour mener des
concertations avec les acteurs et comme
vous êtes vraiment dans l'actualité et
vous le savez cette mission va rendre
ses conclusions vendredi et je peux vous
dire ici au sénat que ces travaux
serviront de base à la rédaction d'une
ordonnance qui sera publié fin avril
monsieur sénateurs voyez le ministre la
ministre du travail qui réunira
d'ailleurs les partenaires sociaux
vendredi pour aborder ce sujet dans lé
cadre le groupe de travail paritaire de
l'agenda social sur les formes
particulières d'emploi
vous avez terminé votre question par il
me reste quelques secondes tarder votre
question par le rôle de l'inspection du
travail
vous avez raison à l'inspection du
travail a les compétences qu'elle est
compétente pour contrôler l'application
du droit du travail
lorsqu'on est dans le cadre d'un contrat
de travail d'un lien de subordination
cela étant elle peut et c'est vrai
intervenir notamment lorsqu il peut y
avoir un travail salarié dissimulé et
transmettre au procureur de la
république
un certain nombre de procédures pour ce
qu'on doit falloir que la défaillance
depuis 2015 voilà monsieur le sénateur
ce que je voulais porter à votre
connaissance pour cette question merci
la réplique de monsieur jacques 1 pour
25 secondes
je prends acte de votre réponse monsieur
le ministre mais le droit vous demande
d'arrêter avec cette fable de
l'indépendance nous venons déposé une
nouvelle proposition de loi saisissez
vous en elle vous permettra de
requalifier en masse par action de
groupe et de rendre enfin transparent
l'algorithme ces travailleurs ne sont
pas des travailleurs de seconde zone et
ses plateformes ne doivent pas rester
des zones de non droit social merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue annie del
mon corps aux polices pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
après l'année terrible que nous avons
vécu l'arrivée des vaccins contre le
virus l'est entrevoir un espoir celui
d'un retour à la vie normale que les
français malgré leur discipline leur
solidarité leur remarquable patience
n'en peuvent plus d'attendre
tous nos soignants se sont mobilisés
pour protéger la population notamment
les plus fragiles
pour ma part j'ai oeuvré dans un centre
de vaccination pour personnes
handicapées ce week end et je me suis
réjoui de constater comme partout
ailleurs sur le territoire une nette
augmentation des capacités de
vaccination
je crains néanmoins à la lumière de ce
qui a suivi que les événements de ce
week-end ne soit qu'une accélération en
trompe l'oeil
l'implication générale de tous les
acteurs tranche avec l'image que renvoie
le dgs et son directeur qui n'a cessé
d'enchaîner les imprécisions et les
décisions contestables et contestées
parmi les dernières en date
il y à celle de l'impossibilité des
médecins général
liste de pouvoir commander des doses la
semaine du 8 mars afin de les livrer aux
pharmacies d'officine
après leur avoir demandé d'assurer une
partie des vaccinations des patients à
risque les voilà maintenant contraints
de déprogrammer les rendez vous prévus
ici il à nos collègues médecins peut
témoigner de l'annulation de 200 rendez
vous il s'agit au mieux d'un couac qui
ne sera pas le premier dans la gestion
de cette épidémie
à chaque jour une nouvelle stratégie
c'est insupportable monsieur le ministre
nous n'avons tout ce qu'un seul souhait
celui que la campagne s'accélère nous
disposons d'une force de frappe
considérable qui ne demande qu'à être
sollicités au premier rang de laquelle
les médecins mais aussi les pharmaciens
et les pompiers dans la mobilisation
pourrait permettre de multiplier par dix
les capacités de vaccination
aussi je vous le demande monsieur le
ministre pourquoi avoir laissé le dgs
infliger un tel camouflet aux médecins
généralistes si ce n'est pour masquer
une nouvelle pénurie
merci chers collègues la parole à
olivier derand mobilise des solidarités
de la santé madame la sénatrice j'ai
répondu tout à l'heure sur la fin sur la
phrase ils ont été obligés d'annuler des
rendez vous la semaine prochaine je vous
lis dans ce serait dommage parce que les
doses sont bien livrés cette semaine on
va faire un calcul on va faire un calcul
c'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
pour les français en fait pour les
protéger
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs dont
je pense qu'on peut être satisfait de sa
collectivement quelles que soient nos
bords politiques et les enjeux
politiques du moment
madame la sénatrice on va faire un
calcul les médecins libéraux qui se sont
déclarés candidats pour vacciner ils
sont au total cumulé pas loin de
quarante mille c'est à dire un petit
environ la moitié peut être un petit peu
moins de la moitié des médecins libéraux
mais c'est beaucoup c'est très bien ils
ont reçu une livraison 350000 vaccins et
livraison de cinq cent mille vaccin donc
ils ont déjà reçu 850 mille vaccin
d'accord depuis la semaine dernière
sur ces huit cent cinquante mille
vaccins nous avons la trace de 450000
vaccination ça veut dire qu'il ya encore
quatre cent mille vaccins qui n'ont pas
été injectés aux patients et qui ont été
reçus avec selon les commandes déjà ya
une semaine
est content que vous avez raison à nous
dire et nous signifier que lorsqu'un
vaccins arrivent sur le territoire il
faut pas qu'ils attendent dans un frigo
qui sont immédiatement donné un malade
je suis d'accord avec vous même la
sénatrice cette semaine les médecins la
semaine dernière ont commandé sept cent
soixante mille vaccins supplémentaires
ils arrivent jeudi et vendredi dans les
officines de tout le pays ils sont
destinés aux médecins qui les ont
commandé portant ainsi à 1 million 600
mille vaccins disponibles commandé par
des médecins libéraux en vue d'être
injecté chez leurs malades pour les
protéger si je fais donc le calcul avec
vous sur 1 million 600 mille vaccins qui
ont été reçus à date de vendredi soir
450 milles environ auront été injectés
ce qui reste encore de l'ordre de 1
million cent mille vaccin injecté en
l'espace de quinze jours avant la
prochaine commande qui sera ouverte aux
médecins la sénatrice au sénat et vous
avez eu aussi raison vous m'avez dit
c'est bien que les médecins maxime et
quand est ce que vous ferez vacciner les
pharmaciens c'est pas normal
vous avez raison nous avons une
livraison faible de vaccins la semaine
prochaine ce n'est pas de mon fait c'est
lui laboratoire 288 vaccin ça va servir
à lancer l'amorçage pour les pharmaciens
contenu des doses et des stocks qui dont
les médecins bénéficient à date et je
les remercie pour ça c'est très
important qu'ils vaccinent et qui n'a dû
leur rien du tout et donc nous
permettons en plus par la place en plus
aux pharmaciens de commencer à vacciner
si je ne l'avais pas fait ma la
maçonnerie j'aurais eu au moins une
question au gouvernement sinon deux
voire trois ans dix ans quand est ce que
permettrait aux pharmaciens de vacciner
médecins pharmaciens c'est l'intérêt
général l'intérêt du pays passons les
bons messages aux français et aux
soignants mobiliser c'est l'essentiel
il ya un merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est maintenant un autre collègue
jocelyne guinness pour le groupe union
centriste monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues à question s'adresse au
ministre d outre mer je n'impose au nom
de mon collègue gérard poggia sénateurs
de la nouvelle calédonie comme vous le
savez monsieur le ministre
la nouvelle calédonie est actuellement
en proie à une série de crises crise
institutionnelle et politique
après le renversement du gouvernement il
ya un mois l'actuel gouvernement ne
parvient pas à se trouver un président
cela à la veille d'une probable demande
de troisième référendum sur
l'indépendance crise budgétaire puisque
le territoire doit voter son budget
avant le 31
sous peine d'être placé sous tutelle de
l'état crise industrielle et économique
avec un cours du nickel à son étiage et
le conflit relatif à la vente de lysine
du sud qui heureusement semble
aujourd'hui résolue catastrophes
naturelles avec le cyclone l'iran enfin
maintenant crise sanitaire avec la
détection des premiers cas de covin dans
ce territoire qui jouissait jusque là de
son statut privilégié de zone qu'ovide
free et de se se retrouve entièrement
confinée depuis lundi
l'impression générale qui se dégage est
alarmante ce sont les dix plaies
d'égypte monsieur le ministre la france
n'est pas seulement l'hexagone c'est
aussi la nouvelle calédonie or face à
cette situation exceptionnelle
les réponses de l'état sont elles à la
hauteur allez-vous pris la mesure de la
crise que traverse le territoire néo
calot de caledonia quelle est votre
stratégie pour y remédier je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre d
août robert à travers vous madame la
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur gérard
poadja qui est actuellement même sur le
sur le caillou on vous avait listé les
nombreux défis auxquels évidemment la
nouvelle calédonie est confronté si on
on commence par l' usine du sud on se
félicite au nom du gouvernement sur
l'autorité du premier ministre du
ministre de l'économie des finances de
voir effectivement la conclusion de cet
accord entre les différentes parties sur
lequel l'état le gouvernement s'est
largement investi dans le cade
évidemment de la gestion du calendrier
de la reprise dans le cade aussi et bien
sûr des expositions financière
extraordinaire que le parlement a bien
voulu d'ailleurs concédé pour cette
cuisine du sud il faut le rappeler
l'effort et les collectifs et les
nationales on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir
le nouvel enjeu et les sanitaires ou la
vie dit en me français au lycée futuna
et la nouvelle case unis étaient covit
free ce n'est désormais plus le cas
depuis la fin de semaine dernière là
aussi évidemment la solidarité nationale
est complètement appelé alors déjà pour
le confinement général que nous
connaissons en nouvelle calédonie
à hélices et futuna sûr évidemment le
renfort sanité un stand de choses vont
se déployer dans les temps qui viendront
un renfort sanitaire également qui ce
qui doit se faire en lien avec wallis et
futuna sur laquelle la situation est
encore plus difficile qu'en nouvelle
calédonie soutien économique et
financier évidemment jusqu'à ce
confinement général on a donné lieu à un
certain nombre de fermetures
administratives d'activité économique
touristique et commercial où là aussi
nous serons évidemment au rendez vous
peut enfin bien sûr c'est le calendrier
politique c'est la formation de ce
nouveau gouvernement sur lequel il
n'appartient pas au gouvernement la
république évidemment de faire une
ingérence en la matière enfin on
souhaite que ce gouvernement puisse
évidemment se constituer le plus
rapidement possible pour pouvoir
continuer le travail notamment sur les
implications du oui et du non la date à
laquelle le congrès la nouvelle
calédonie pourra réclamer ce troisième
référendum approche et je les dis au nom
du gouvernement il ya maintenant
quelques jours le gouvernement bien sûr
est prêt à discuter
y compris bien sûr d'un nouvel accord
puisqu'on sait très bien qu'il faut
désormais définir le lendemain de
l'accord de nouméa voilà en quelques
mots en deux minutes pour répondre aux
dix plaies d'égypte que vous avez
rappelé pour le nouveau la nouvelle
calédonie pour le caillou merci monsieur
le ministre
allez-y vous avez 36 secondes oui merci
monsieur le ministre je connais votre
engagement pour les outre mer mais la
situation générale de la nouvelle qu'a
donnée dramatique et j'aimerais
simplement vous dire qu'il est important
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce ne sera
joutes pas le problème des doses qui
sont attendus pour le vaccin
il me semble qu'il en faudrait dix mille
par semaine et aujourd'hui le compte n'y
est pas donc je compte sur vous pour
surveiller tout ça merci beaucoup merci
chers collègues
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
céline boulay speroni pour le groupe
l'est républicain
mes chers collègues la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur si les affrontements entre
groupes de jeunes existe depuis
longtemps
on est en train d'assister une explosion
inédite de délinquance de rue et de la
violence juvénile
rien que cette semaine plusieurs jeunes
de moins de 15 ans ont été grièvement
blessés et c'est tous les jours qu'on
assiste à un événement dramatique
cette nuit encore à la veille de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
mais en plein coeur du 16e
arrondissement de paris dans un quartier
pourtant réputée calme
il y a eu des affrontements violents il
est hors de question de s'abandonner à
la fête la fatalité ni de laisser
s'installer une sorte de résignation
collective laisser croire qu'on a tout
essayé n'est pas acceptable
monsieur le ministre malgré vos efforts
vous n'arrivez pas à rétablir l'ordre
les policiers sont épuisés et héroïque
mais on a le sentiment qu'il est plus
facile pour la préfecture de police
d'évacuer les berges de seine que de
lutter contre la délinquance de rue j'ai
informé par courrier votre préfet le 27
janvier que la tension monte notamment
porte de saint cloud où j'ai assisté à
des heures pas de réponse
un mois et demi après lorsque vous le
croiserez monsieur le ministre
n'hésitez pas à lui remettre ce courrier
que je tiens à votre disposition
lorsque en matière de police et de
justice
il ne s'agit pas de répondre au coup par
coup mais de mettre en place une
véritable politique sérieuse et
cohérente
vous vous êtes déplacé avec monsieur le
premier ministre à bové à lyon cette
semaine pour constater l'escaladé de la
violence
ma question est donc simple quelles
mesures opérationnelles comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre immédiatement pour que
les villes ne devienne pas le terrain
d'affrontement systématique de jeunes
armés jusqu'aux dents sur fond de
revendications de territoires des
réseaux sociaux je vous remercie
la parole fut gérald darmanin ministre
de l'intérieur merci merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice face
question ça me touche en tant que mise
intérieur bien évidemment mais quand
vous parlez d'enfants de 11 12 ou 13 ans
vous même moins de 15 ans je ne sais pas
très bien ce que la police la
gendarmerie préfèrent de plus que les
parents ou que le suivi éducatif d'une
partie de ces personnes
que voulez vous que nous fassions que
mettre en prison des enfants 12 ans
quand vite armés jusqu'aux dents
mais madame la sénatrice ceci n'est pas
raisonnable
il y a dans les attaques effectivement
deux rixes que nous connaissons nos
enfants de 11 12 ou 13 ans en essonne où
sur la plaque parisienne des armes
blanches
un car c'est vrai souvent des petits
couteaux de cuisine souvent des opinel
le plus souvent ce qu'ils trouvent sur
la voirie armés jusqu'aux dents c'était
pas ça et ne confondons pas ce qui se
passe devant le lycée du 16e
arrondissement qui est évidemment à
déplorer mais qui n'a rien à voir avec
les violences urbaines de règlements de
comptes de trafic de drogue qui a
abreuvé à tourcoing et roubaix à
marseille
je pense qu'il faut savoir distinguer
les choses et tenir des propos plus
équilibré ce qui est certain madame la
célèbre région de question d'évoquer
c'est que bien sûr les réseaux sociaux
et les messageries cryptée empêche
aujourd'hui de faire le travail de
police d'hier et d'avant-hier et nous
allons parler de la loire enseignement
dans quelques semaines dans cet
hémicycle au sénat j'espère que le sénat
nous accompagnera et la majorité
sénatoriale en premier pour pouvoir
intervenir
et pour pouvoir notamment permettre
services du renseignement de police en
soit ait eu lieu la direction des
renseignements de la préfecture de
police à paris pour pouvoir surveiller
ses réseaux sociaux snapshot en
particulier mais aussi le télégramme on
a zappé signal qui sont aujourd'hui
aveugle pour les services de police nous
allons parler la sécurité globale de la
sénatrice nous aimerions en effet on en
discutera dans quelques jours que le
sénat puisse permettre notamment aux
policiers municipaux et pourquoi pas à
paris parce qu'elle crée la loi de
mettre des agents des amendes
forfaitaires délictuelle parle moins de
18 ans malheureusement le sénat a
supprimé ses dispositions en commission
donc je suis d'accord pour travailler
avec vous mais ne confondons pas les
violences urbaines
sur fond de règlements de compte et ce
qui peut se passer effectivement tout à
fait déplorable pour des enfants de 11
et 12 ans bien merci monsieur le
ministre il vous reste 17 secondes
oui quand je parle de jama armés
jusqu'aux dents me dis qu hier soir il
avait des marteaux et des couteaux dans
les poches par des mets moi du peu et je
ne pense pas que l'état doive se
défausser en permanence quitte sur les
parents sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
des discussions qu'on devra avoir bien
sûr mais la réponse elle doit être ferme
elle doit être immédiate parce que les
les habitants de paris et les français
ne peuvent pas être pris en otage en
permanence par ces violences
inacceptables et qui marquent l'opinion
publique tous les jours que dieu fait
aujourd'hui en france il ya la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue gilbert
roger pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
l'afrique du sud et l'inde ont pris
l'initiative d'un texte proposant
d'accorder une dérogation temporaire de
certaines obligations afin que tous les
pays puissent produire les vaccins
sans les brevets cette obligation
découle de l'accord
excusez-moi de l'accord sur les aspects
du droit de propriété intellectuelle qui
touche le commerce
en effet aujourd'hui la grande majorité
des 225 millions de doses antico vides
ont été administrées dans quelques pays
riches et producteurs de vaccins tandis
que la plupart des pays à revenu faible
ou intermédiaire attendent encore je me
félicite qu à la suite de l'appel lancé
par l' oms et relayé par le président de
la république monsieur emmanuel macron
les pays du g7 se soit engagé à partager
une partie de leurs vaccins et à verser
des sommes importantes pour financer le
mécanisme kovacs monsieur le ministre
sur ce point pour des vous nous indiquer
précisément quel est le décaissement
réels effectués par la france sur sa
contribution financière aux différents
programmes de vaccination pour les pays
du sud
je souhaiterais aussi vous interroger
sur un autre point
afin de clarifier la position française
la france officiellement fait le maximum
pour les pays les plus pauvres disposent
afin qu'ils disposent des vaccins contre
le coc vide à l'om c'est l'union
européenne dont fait partie la france
s'oppose formellement à une dérogation
temporaire à la protection des brevets
médicaux
aussi monsieur le ministre afin d'être
en conformité avec toutes les
déclarations et afin d'amplifier
l'ambition du mécanisme kovacs
le gouvernement français est il prêt à
soutenir l'initiative inde au sud
africaine pour une levée des barrières
protégeant les brevets le vaccin anti
qu'ovide merci chaque collège
la parole à nous faisons yves le drian
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères oui monsieur le sénateur
gilbert roger vous avez raison la
solidarité internationale contre le coc
vite c'est pas uniquement une affaire
morale c'est une affaire morale c'est
une exigence morale mais c'est aussi une
exigence d'efficacité et collective pour
vaincre le plan de la pandémie est à cet
égard il y à un instrument que nous
portons que vous avez cités et qui
fonctionne qui s'appelle kovacs cet
instrument a été initiée à la demande de
la france et de l'allemagne avec le
soutien de l'union européenne il est
maintenant partagée par la
quasi-totalité des pays du monde parce
que nous souhaitons comme vous je crois
faire en sorte que le vaccin soit un
bien public mondial
et c'est pour cette raison que nous
avons mobilisé au sein du coc vax
aujourd'hui 2008 plus de 2 milliards de
dollars pour permettre au pays où 92
pays bien identifié les plus faibles de
pouvoir axe avoir accès immédiatement
pas quand on sera en mesure de faire une
unité de production en inde ou en
république sud africaine tout de suite
avec les laboratoires qui ont passé
contrat avec l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
c'est à dire très clairement identifiés
dans leur traçabilité de leur sécurité
et ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
puisque vous souhaitiez des chiffres
c'est les financements qui sont
aujourd'hui mobilisées permettront
d'aboutir avant la fin de l'année à
avoir plus de 2 milliards de doses pour
les pays qui sont les plus en difficulté
gratuitement
financé par la communauté internationale
donc bien public mondial
ce ne sont pas des voeux c'est de la
réalité et concrètement aujourd'hui il y
à déjà les premières doses qui sont
arrivés au nigeria au ghana en côte
d'ivoire je peux vous faire toute la
liste si vous voulez avec le nombre de
doses le ghana 600000 la côte d'ivoire
504000 le nigeria 4 millions de doses le
sénégal 3 300 milles etc etc
donc cette possible opération initiée
par la france qui marche
comme quoi lorsqu'on déclarons
tu vas te faire du vaccin bien public
mondial on était au rendez vous des
réalités et c'est aussi pour notre
propre sécurité
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant à madame
isabelle raymond pas verrou pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
ces messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre de la
justice
il est aujourd'hui dans nos prisons plus
de soixante mille détenus avec une
densité qui frôle 120 % en un an d'arrêt
au plan national
vous en êtes vous même qui était cette
situation est d'autant plus préoccupante
que le nombre de détenus a connu une
chute et historique qui n'est
malheureusement pas lié à une baisse de
la délinquance mais au double effet d'un
quasi arrêt des juridictions pendant le
confinement des mesures de libération
exceptionnelles prises pour limiter le
risque épidémique
cette surpopulation carcérale chronique
conduit à ce que 700 détenus et c'est
vous qui dites couche aujourd'hui sur
des matelas posés à même le sol dans les
cellules dans certaines maisons d'arrêt
les taux d'occupation sont affolants
193% anime 170 à toulouse seysses 150% à
villepinte
comment s'étonner dès lors que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
condamne la france en utilisant les mots
de dégradant et d'inhumain cette
situation me ce ministre n'honore pas
notre pays nous avons bien compris que
votre souhait d'instaurer un numerus
clausus carcéral et que pour vous malgré
l'augmentation de la délinquance c'est
le quantum des peines qui devra
s'adapter au nombre de places de prison
le président de la république avait
promis la création de 15000 places de
prison pendant son quinquennat si les
objectifs annoncés avaient été tenus on
ne parlerait peut-être pas de
surpopulation carcérale en france
comment expliquez vous que nous serons
passés de 15000 places nouvelles pendant
le quinquennat à 2000 ou 3000 dont une
partie d'ailleurs avait été lancé par le
prédécesseur d manueel macron
merci chers collègues la parole gabriel
a tall secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre et porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice raymond pavé rouge au prix
d'abord d'excuser l'absence de mon
collègue garde des sceaux qui retenu au
banc au sénat et qui aurait je le crois
vraiment à l'assemblée nationale qui
aurai je crois emea pouvoir vous vous
répondre parce que c'est un sujet vous
le savez qui le mobilise tout
particulièrement et sur lequel il est
très engagé et sur lequel je le sais le
sénat aussi est très engagé je sais
qu'un texte est examiné sur ce sujet
lundi qu'il a été adoptée je constate
que régulièrement dans les séances de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
voit que cette question revient de
l'ensemble des groupes
je crois que c'est une marque aussi au
sénat d'engagement particulier sur cette
question là parce que c'est un défi de
société
vous l'avez dit nous sommes dans une
situation de surpopulation carcérale qui
engendre des situations indignes
ça fait un certain nombre d'années que
cette situation se développe et où il
faut prendre des mesures
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république s'était
engagé effectivement un programme de
15000 création de places supplémentaires
7000 ont déjà été engagés le programme
pour 7000 est engagé il en reste huit
mille et l'engagement qui a été pris par
le garde des sceaux c'est d'engager ce
programme de huit milles supplémentaires
d'ici à la fin du quinquennat ce sera
fait et au printemps le garde des sceaux
communiquera sur les sites retenus pour
développer ce plan mais vous le savez la
question n'est pas seulement les places
c'est aussi les alternatives à
l'incarcération
c'est pour ça que nous travaillons et
que nous renforçons les travaux
d'intérêt général et toutes les mesures
qui permettent une alternative à
l'incarcération
elles ont d'ailleurs augmenté depuis
plusieurs années parce que nous avons
fait le choix de les développer
oui c'est une situation qui est très
difficile et nous nous y attaques ont
encore une fois avec la création de
places avec ces alternatives à
l'incarcération
nous allons poursuivre nous avons une
ambition extrêmement forte pour
continuer sur cette voie et je sais que
le cnra sera aussi au rendez-vous cette
mobilisation
parce que à nouveau c'est un défi de
société qui doit collectivement nous
réunir
à chaque collègue vous avez une réplique
de 19 secondes souhaité l'augmentation
de la délinquance dans notre pays si n'y
a ni moyens conséquents ni volonté de
construire de nouvelles places de prison
la france continuera d'être condamnée
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
[Applaudissements]
il ya un cher collègue nous en avons
terminé avec cette séance de questions
d'actualité je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 17
mars à 15 heures je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi
rénovant la gouvernance du service
public d'eau potable et d'assainissement
en guadeloupe
la séance est suspendue voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur l'antenne
de public sénat tout de suite et bien
place au débrief de ces questions
c'était variés 7 est riche et on va tout
de suite à aller voir notre streamer
politique jean jean massiet à l'argent
qu'est ce que la communauté a retenu
avec et bien tous ces échanges cet après
midi jean qu'est-ce qui a marqué les
internautes cet après midi dans les
échanges des sénateurs qu'est ce que la
communauté rom dans les échanges de
sénateur et bien énormément de choses
aujourd'hui on a notamment beaucoup
entendu parler de la question du coville
et les des internautes qui était pas du
tout convaincu par la réponse notamment
à la question de pie rouge oulias
pourquoi est ce que les sénateurs
peuvent s'asseoir sur un siège sur deux
au sénat et nous on peut pas le faire au
théâtre c'est vrai que ça cette phrase
de pierre ouzeau les as a très très bien
marché les internautes ont été d'accord
avec cette question là et la réponse a
pas vraiment convaincu la réponse de
roselyne bachelot sur la question des
oligo également la question d'espère
benbassa a beaucoup séduit les
internautes
enfin la question des eaux rigourd est
posée et la réponse de jean yves le
drian quelque chose d'intéressant que
les internautes ont relevé jean yves le
drian n'a pas prononcé le mot génocide
alors même que certains pays le font je
pense notamment au canada et aux états
unis là les internautes se sont dit
c'est dommage c'est dans ces moments là
qu'on a besoin que le chef de la
diplomatie utilise les mots disent les
termes notamment le mot génocide
lorsqu'on parle de la situation des
ouïgours donc voila un petit peu les
sujets qui ont particulièrement retenu
l'attention des internautes aujourd'hui
et oui un deux traits
nombreux sujets au programme de cette
séance de questions d'actualité merci
beaucoup
genre pour toutes ces explications et je
rappelle que dans stella n'a stream tout
à l'heure tu vas recevoir le sénateur
philippe bas les questeurs ex président
de la commission des lois voilà pour la
promo tout de suite et bien on va
commencer à les réactions saleh des
conférences on va rejoindre steve
jourdain steve car vous êtes avec le
président du groupe et l'air au sénat
vous êtes avec bruno retailleau pour
être revient sur cette séance de
questions d'actualité
oui bruno retailleau bonjour on parle
beaucoup de cette violence entre jeunes
ces rixes entre bandes rivales alors
xavier bertrand parle d'une france
orange mécanique valérie pécresse parle
elle de guerre des bandes vous comment
vous qualifier la situation en france
aujourd'hui c'est une chronique qui
devient quotidienne d'une barbarie
ordinaire et les choses sont claires on
vient d'entendre le ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'a pas vraiment donné
aux sénateurs qui lui posait la question
sur ce sujet la sénatrice qu'il n'y a
pas fait de proposition moi je pense que
si on ne renverse pas la table cette
hyper violence va se généraliser
alors comment la renverse on la renverse
en faisant et en assumant un changement
de pied total notamment une révolution
pénale première chose il faut centrer
sur la victime
la décision judiciaire pénal aujourd'hui
il ya trop de jeunes je vais vous donner
un cas très concrets un jeune mineur 15
ans à nantes 34 vols cambriolages et il
écope d'un rappel à la loi je suis
désolé la loi n'a pas être rappelé elle
à être appliquée deuxième principe à
chaque délit il faut une sanction
il faut une peine et que cette peine
soit exécutée et donc je propose la
création comme aux pays-bas de prison
spécifique pour les courtes peines pour
des mineurs pour les enfermer parce que
ces jeunes ne prennent pas conscience de
la gravité de leurs actes
seul un enfermement de quelques semaines
peut caractériser une vraie sanction
alors la sanction
c'est le début de l'éducation parfois
alors gérald darmanin
dit que la responsabilité n'incombe pas
seulement gouvernement ou à l'étal
incombe aussi aux parents vous êtes
d'accord avec ça mais je suis d'accord
simplement l'état ne doit pas se
défausser et six ministres gérald
darmanin indique que la responsabilité
des parents est engagée puis dis
solennellement aujourd'hui qu'il y à un
article du code pénal qui permet à
l'état de poursuivre des parents
défaillants en matière d'autorisation
pardon de responsabilité parentale
pourquoi d'ailleurs lorsque nous avons
proposé il ya quelques semaines
ici au sénat un amendement qui voulait
priver les familles défaillante
justement dette sociale dead familiales
d'allocations familiales pourquoi le
gouvernement s'est il opposé
on est dans la communication pure et
sane abuse pas les français
en tout cas ça ne les a bus plus donc
pour vous il faut sanctionner les
parents je pense que quand il ya une
responsabilité parentale engagé il ya le
code pénal le code pénal c'est la loi il
n'est pas fait pour ne pas être
appliquée au contraire et si monsieur le
ministre a des preuves que des familles
sont défaillantes et impliqué et bien
qu'il use de la loi existant à travers
cet article du code pénal parce que la
situation actuelle le confinement
l'absence de perspective permet
d'expliquer selon vous cette
augmentation des violents non non il n'y
a pas d'excusés ce qui explique l'hyper
violence c'est l'hyper laxisme
voilà je pense que dans le bilan par
ailleurs si maigre si modeste hemayma
cran sur cinq à qena
le pire le pire échec ce sera le
régalien ce sera la sécurité
l'insécurité dont on a vu aujourd'hui
qu'elle avait franchi un palier en terme
de violence et en termes de territoire
désormais les territoires ruraux sont
malheureusement aussi concernés
désormais le phénomène des bandes
malgré à monsieur de darmana ses 24 %
d'augmentation en une année seulement
voilà le bilan de monsieur emmanuel
macron si vous deviez résumer comment
vous expliquer ce phénomène des bandes
qui a toujours existé finalement il n'a
pas toujours existé dans cette mesure là
certes les blousons noirs etc
mais là on a une généralisation ya plus
une nuit il ya plus d'une semaine qui se
passe sans qu'on ait une jeune fille
tabac s'est noyé dans la seine sans
qu'on ait un garçon qui était
pratiquement laissé pour mort des morts
aussi mineur donc je pense que là on a
malheureusement le délitement d'abord
une école qui ne transmet plus
suffisamment parfois des familles qui
sont défaillantes sur le plan de la
responsabilité mais surtout une
abdication des autorités politiques
parce que en france on essaie d'éviter
la prison eh bien non la prison comme le
montre l'exemple des pays-bas est bien
la prison peut être une réponse sur des
jeunes qui n'arrivent pas à comment
dirais-je avoir ni par anticipation mais
ni les conséquences des actes qu'ils
peuvent commettre et qui sont vraiment
très grave donc mettre le paquet sur le
répressif merci beaucoup bruno
retailleau merci d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci merci beaucoup steve pour cette
première réaction sur ce plateau j'ai
plaisir d'accueillir sophie primas
bonjour vous êtes président de la
commission des affaires économiques
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
face à vous patrick kanner vous êtes
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
et sénateur du nord et nous sommes en
visio avec benjamin morel maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université paris 2 panthéon assas et
tout de suite on va rejoindre et bien
quand un quentin qu'elle met dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
on vient d'en parler avec bruno
retailleau la question d'erick ça a été
abordé lors de cette séance quentin
c'est pas la première fois un call est
abordée au sein des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat
notamment par le groupe et l'herbe ça a
été encore le cas cette fois-ci tout
fait on soulève une question de jean
raymond hugo n'est élu dans l'essonne
c'était semaine dernière et donc cette
fois ci est bien c est céline boulay
speroni qui a posé la question et les
élus de paris élue en particulier du
16ème arrondissement où il ya eu hier
encore des violences devant un lycée
avec des armes blanches et encore ce
matin un blessé grave à déplorer
cet élu de paris a parlé d'une explosion
de violences de rues dans sa question
d'actualité jouer ses côtés un autre
extrait préparé par alice bardot l'ordre
les policiers sont épuisés et héroïque
mais on a le sentiment qu'il est plus
facile pour la préfecture de police
d'évacuer les berges de seine que de
lutter contre la délinquance de rue
quelles mesures opérationnelles
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre
immédiatement pour que les villes ne
devienne pas le terrain d'affrontement
systématique de jeunes armés jusqu'aux
dents sur fond de revendications de
territoires de réseaux sociaux je vous
remercie au casse parce que elle
s'exprimait elle parlait à gérald
darmanin qui se trouvait juste à côté
d'elle assis sur le banc des ministres
sur une chaise juste à sa gauche et qui
lui faisait des noms de la tête pendant
sa question est justement on va écouter
un extrait de la réponse des mises de
l'intérieur
on vous parlait d'enfants de 11 12 ou 13
avril vous même moins de 15 ans je sais
pas très bien ce que la police la
gendarmerie pc de plus que les parents
ou que le suivi éducatif d'une partie de
ces personnes
bien sûr les réseaux sociaux et les
messageries cryptée empêche aujourd'hui
de faire le travail de police d'hier et
d'avant-hier et nous allons parler de la
loire enseignement dans quelques
semaines dans cet hémicycle au sénat
j'espère que le sénat nous accompagnera
et la majorité sénatoriale en premier
pour pouvoir intervenir
et pour pouvoir notamment permettre
services du renseignement de police dans
son feuilleton de la direction du
renseignement de la préfecture de police
de paris pour surveiller ces réseaux
sociaux snapshot en particulier mais
aussi le télégramme ones après signal
gérald darmanin qui a mis la pression
sur le sénat rôle rappelle la
proposition de loi de sécurité globale
arrive le 16 mars en séance elle
ce texte a déjà été examiné en
commission des lois et les sénateurs ont
enlevé certaines mesures qui permettait
pas un plat à la police municipale
d'agir sur certains dossiers et donc
gérald darmanin aujourd'hui renvoie la
balle à l'envoyeur en disant au sénat et
bien falloir accompagner maintenant
aussi la réponse pénale la réponse de la
police
avec cette proposition de loi merci
merci beaucoup quand un pour tous de ses
explications votre réaction sophie
primas c'est le phénomène des bandes ce
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau mais on
les a rarement vu aussi jeunes aussi
violent et qu'avez vous pensé de la
réponse à l'instant de gérald darmanin
qui dit qu'il ya aussi la responsabilité
des parents celle des réseaux sociaux et
puis celle du sénat qui n'a peut-être
pas été à la hauteur sur la sécurité
globale nous dit il moi ce que je pense
et ce qui me préoccupe beaucoup c'est la
montée de la violence d'une façon
générale on en parlait tout à l'heure
bien sûr ça se matérialise aujourd'hui
par derrick st-john et de gens de plus
en plus jeunes dans des quartiers mais
aussi dans tous les partis de la france
sur des prétextes qui sont bien sûr
souvent des trafics qui sont perturbés
mais aussi des rixes d'amoureuse d'aidé
enfin on est dans une diversité des
soucis aujourd'hui qui mènent à la
violence soient de l'ultra violence
donc moi ça ça me préoccupe les gens se
désinhiber chez ces violences totalement
désinhibé qui est le résultat à mon avis
de dizaines d'années peut-être où on a
perdu le sens des choses et c'est alors
la réponse de gérald darmanin bon il
fait de la politique politicienne sur un
sujet qui me semble être être est très
très important je crois qu'on aura une
responsabilité collective dans la lutte
contre la violence et l'éducation
nationale je pense qu'il faut
réapprendre à exprimer quand on a des
difficultés il faut apprendre simplement
à mettre des mots sur des maux
pardonnez-moi émail x je pense qu'on a
est évidemment une responsabilité des
parents simplement aujourd'hui on arrive
pratiquement à une deuxième génération
c'est à dire que les parents des enfants
qui sont aujourd'hui assez violents
étaient eux mêmes dans une spirale de la
violence qu'on est vraiment dans ce
quelque chose qui s'ancre dans les
territoires il ya la responsabilité
jacques dire collective de l'éducation
pas que de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi de tous les services sociaux
accompagnement la responsabilité de la
justice qui doit être plus percutante et
plus juste et plus approprié dans sa
réponse à l'âge et au niveau de
délinquance et probablement avec des
réponses plus systématique et plus
graduées plus proportionnée patrick
kanner des responsabilités partagées
c'est ce que vous nous brosser comme
tableau qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous qu'ils vous êtes occupé de la
politique de la ville de la jeunesse en
tant que ministre qu'est ce que vous
inspire cette situation actuelle et
cette hausse des violences 25% en un an
et puis des violences de plus en plus
grave cela m'inspire vraiment une
démarche de nos caricatures parce que si
on caricature d'une manière ou d'une
autre ces phénomènes
on ne trouvera pas la bonne solution je
voudrais un acquis caricature la bruno
retailleau que vous avez entendu à lens
je veux dire c'est qu'elle venir il n'y
a pas de solution parfaite aujourd'hui
et je partage l'avis de madame prime à
la responsabilité est collective
elle revient d'abord aux adultes non pas
que je veuille des douanes et des
enfants de 14 15 ans de d'actes qui sont
absolument insupportables et d'ailleurs
je rappelle que la responsabilité pénale
commence à 13 ans lui donc il y a des
enfants qui vont être condamnés
il convient peut-être de la prison ferme
en tout cas être dans les centres fermés
pour leur permettre bien voilà de
retrouver le sens de la réalité parce
que derrière cela
l'hyper numérique aujourd'hui à moutier
l'hyper violence
on voit bien les violences faites aux
femmes
en tout cas fait à des jeunes femmes
sont finalement accepté comme une sorte
de banalités dans la société que les
réseaux asociaux concours finalement à
désinhiber le respect qu'on doit à
n'importe quel autre être humain
oui si ce film est un tout ça le film et
ses partages
ça fait partie ça devient une sorte de
challenge permanent pour des jeunes en
termes d' affirmation personnelle mais
aussi territoriale d'où ces phénomènes
de bandes
donc je pense qu'il faut jouer sur deux
tableaux tolérance zéro en matière de
sanction parce que voilà quand on fait
on doit être sanctionné mais aussi
mobilisation de tous les adultes et je
voudrais reprendre cette phrase qui moi
m'a beaucoup presque ému de la part de
romain colas le maire de
boussy-saint-antoine qui a vu un jeune
de 14 ans mourir dans les rues de sa
ville
ce maire socialiste dit quand deux
gamins meurt dans de telles conditions
puisqu'il ya bien d'autres gamins dans
une autre commune de l'essonne quand
deux gamins moeurs de telles conditions
c'est d'abord un échec des adultes et
j'aimerais que voilà que nous balayons
nous en tant qu'adulte devant notre
porte mais poursuivent les parents
défaillants pour reprendre ce que disent
les premières retailleau a lens il y a
des parents défaillants les poursuivre
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs dans le chou
quelle forme vie j'entends encore une
fois à dire on va leur supprimer les
allocations familiales dont ce sera la
double peine
parce que une mère de famille qui a cinq
enfants toute seule à élever et qui
travaillent et bien voilà elle ne peut
pas être parfaitement être dans sa
fonction éducatrice donc la société a
évolué les couples se disloque
les familles monoparentales sont le plus
en plus nombreuses dans des quartiers en
grande difficulté sociale et économique
et donc il faut des réponses adaptées et
je vous avoue je crois que c'est
l'humilité qui dois je crois marqué
notre débat ce soir
sur ce sujet je vous avoue que healy a
peut-être à poser tous les problèmes sur
la table et avoir non pas un grenelle de
l'éducation sur ces questions là mais au
moins au moins ne pas se jeter telle ou
telle vérité absolue dans la figure
personne n'est capable de traiter de
manière complète et sérieuse ces
difficultés qui malheureusement
aujourd'hui claque à notre figure
oui je voulais agir parce que le
président kenner évidemment parle
de cette proposition de suppression des
allocations familiales dont on parle de
façon comme un marronnier
ce qui est important dans tout ça c'est
la responsabilisation des parents et
comment est-ce qu'on amène les parents a
entré dans l'éducation davantage de
leurs enfants
je me souviens et pardon pour le
président caennais remet d'une
disposition qui avait été prise par eric
ciotti il y a une dizaine d'années qui
visait à lutter contre l'absentéisme au
collège et au lycée et qui disait au
bout d'un processus très long si les
parents ne sont pas rentrés dans ce
processus et si on n'arrive pas à lutter
contre l'absentéisme
alors il y a suppression des allocations
familiales en fait ça a été supprimée
dans le mandat de françois hollande peu
importe sur la raison que ça ne marchait
pas assez ont supprimé pas les
allocations familiales
mais c'était une grande victoire car en
réalité on avait de très très nombreux
cas qui avaient été traités dans chacun
des lycées de façon individuelle et vous
n'avez remis les parents avec les
enfants dans cette nécessité dans cette
responsabilisation
voilà je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir dans l'état d'esprit il faut
trouver quelque chose qui au bout face
un peu peur pour qu'en fait dans le
processus de remise en lien des parents
et des enfants
il y ait une responsabilité aussi des
parents je crois que c'est ça l'objectif
on va continuer les réactions salle des
conférences tout de suite steve vous
êtes avec la sénatrice les républicains
jacqueline eustache brinio lui
jacqueline eustache brinio bonjour on va
parler ce projet de loi contre les
séparatistes qui est actuellement
discuté au sénat ce matin dans une
tribune publiée dans le figaro les
églises chrétiennes s'inquiète elle
s'inquiète d'une possible remise en
cause de l'esprit de la loi de 1905
votre opinion à ce sujet alors je crois
que mon l'église s'est exprimée
plusieurs fois nous avons entendu toutes
les églises
je crois qu'il faut que nous fassions
possède un travail pédagogique un
travail d'information sur ce texte en
tout cas en ce qui concerne les cultes
parce que aujourd'hui n'ont pas compris
selon vous ce nouveau texte
alors moi j'ai regardé j'ai lu l'article
il ya une inquiétude sur l'article 6
l'article 6 i concerne pas les
associations cultuelles il concerne les
associations qui reçoit des financements
publics que l'on va demander un certain
nombre d'engagements
bon ce qui est normal
de demander dès lors qu'on reçoit un
engagement public on doit respecter les
valeurs de la république bon ça ça ne
concerne pas les associations cultuelles
puisque par définition laisser les
collectivités ne peuvent pas de donner
deux suivants sont cultes donc ça ne
concerne pas les cultes l'article 6
après il ya l'article 44 j'ai regardé
qui concerne la fermeture les mesures
administratives de fermeture des cultes
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à une
situation qui pose souci on sait très
bien que l'état ferme aujourd'hui des
cultes avec des outils qu'elle est là
mais qui ne suffisent pas donc
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qui est
visé par cette loi on le sait mais en
même temps une loi veut pas viser une
partie là de la population elle doit
concerner tout le monde
voilà je pense que les églises et les
temples de paute restants sont pas
menacé de fermeture par l'article 44
voilà après il ya un article 27 qui dit
que effectivement faudra tous les cinq
ans faire une déclaration bon ça sur la
crue du préfet par louis voilà ça c'est
quand même d'ailleurs il ya déjà
aujourd'hui les rescrit ils sont donnés
pour cinq ans et s'est renouvelée alors
après peut-être qu'il faudra le faire un
peu partout c'est rendu qu'on sent quand
les choses n'ont pas changé et qu'il
faille rassuré que j'aimais ça partait
de très très compliqué ça joue chez nous
j'ai l'impression que vous défendez ce
texte du gouvernement alors non pas que
j'ai des attentats non nourrit d'accord
sur le jeudi sur la question migratoire
est vraiment parler de l'article ce
matin et de l'inquiétude des cultes donc
moi je vous parle de ce que nous allons
ce que nous faisons ce que nous
regardons pour essayer de comprendre
l'inquiétude des cultes et essayer d'y
apporter ou des explications et parfois
peut-être il faudra apporter des
compléments au niveau du sénat pour
rassurer les cultes mais voilà ce que je
veux dire c'est que ans qui compte en ce
qui concerne les cultes le sénat est
plutôt là pour faire de la pédagogie et
peut-être pour écrire des choses pour
rassurer nous devrons rassurer écrire
des choses pour rassurer
ça ne veut pas dire que ce texte me
convient mais vous m'avez posé la
question sur les cultes alors justement
petite dernière question gérald darmanin
été auditionné en ici même la semaine
prochaine il a donné sa définition de la
laïcité pour lisser trois choses
pluralité religieuse liberté de culte
neutralité de l'état mais pas la
discrétion dans l'espace public est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec l'or je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire la discrétion
dans l'espace public
franchement je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire mais aujourd'hui encore d
annoncer que nous devons faire
pour lutter contre cette affirmation
d'une religion qui veut dominer dans un
certain nombre de lieux un certain
nombre de choses et la discrétion dans
l'espace chic je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire faire la laïcité est là qu
elle se redéfinit pas aujourd'hui parce
que nous devons faire face à un certain
nombre de choses
voilà la réciter c'est clair et un
objectif c'est ce qui nous a tous
construits dans le respect de la foi de
chacun et nous devons préserver cela en
tout cas merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
mais derrière c'est d'avoir répondu à ma
question merci à vous merci merci
beaucoup et ce type pour cette réaction
on va tout de suite allé voir benjamin
morel benjamin morel est ce que pour
vous les craintes des églises
chrétiennes qu'elle expose aujourd'hui
dans un appel commun dans le figaro
parce que ces craintes elles sont
fondées lorsque l'on regarde et bien
l'état actuel de ce projet de loi sur le
séparatisme sur le respect des principes
de la république
est ce qu'elles sont totalement fondée
en tout cas vous avez des craintes qui
s'expriment dès le départ sur cette fois
de la part de l'ensemble des cultes un
ce niveau notamment l'audition au sénat
de nos présentations des représentants
de la fédération protestante de france
il ya des questions alors est ce que ça
implique de modifier profondément le
texte est ce que ça implique pour le
parlement au regard de l'examen qui est
le sien et au regard de je serais tenté
de dire des précisions qui peuvent être
apportées dans le cas d'une lecture
génétique de la loi qui conduira ensuite
à faire basculer en tout cas
réinterpréter 1,52 disposition dans un
sens plus favorable à ces cultes ça il
faut voir si vous voulez évidemment pas
mal de choses qui dépendront des décrets
d'application en encore en tant que tel
toutefois il ya en effet des questions
qui se posent des questions qui méritent
d'être posées
et si la loi doit être largement
acceptée il faut que le gouvernement
puisse accepter d'avoir un regard qui
soit un regard critique sur les
dispositions en question quand vous avez
lançons des églises qui très clairement
dès le départ par rapport à cette fois
alors qu'elle n'était pas les premières
visées tire la sonnette d'alarmé
oui donc patrick kane r effectivement un
certain âge de l'église on les a
entendus lors des auditions sur le
séparatisme qui ont dit craindre pour la
liberté de culte on a entendu les
inquiétudes du culte protestant celle du
culte catholique est ce que vous êtes
vous aussi sur cette ligne est ce que
c'est un texte qui met à mal la loi de
1905 à moi j'ai reçu il ya 48 heures la
conférence des évêques de france qui m'a
exprimé en ma qualité de président de
groupe des inquiétudes qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans le grand journal
quotidien qui est le figaro moi je ne
vous cache pas qu'il ya une forme de
paradoxe dans ce texte on veut lutter
contre le séparatisme et en particulier
contre l'islamisme politique et ça je
crois que nous sommes tous d'accord pour
considérer que tout ce qui menace la
république doit être combattu mais je me
demande si on utilise les bons moyens et
est finalement dans cette loi de 1905
qui sépare l'église et l'état qui
protège la liberté de culte et qui
demande à l'état de rester à sa place
mais aussi aux religions de rester à
leur place suivant le fameux adage de
jean jaurès la loi protège la fois à
condition que la foi ne viennent pas
faire la loi et je pense que tout est
résumé à un style brillant disait à peu
près la même chose donc dans ce cadre on
voit dans ce texte un gouvernement qui
commence à venir du contrôle et
finalement les les églises au sens large
du terme et remettre en cause leur
équilibre très fragile mais qui tient
depuis 1805 de cette relation entre
l'état et les églises et finalement nos
amis de des églises me disait de 2
des évêques lui disais mais finalement
en train de vouloir faire un concordat
généralisée alors que le concordat est
une spécificité propre à l'est de notre
de notre pays pour les deux départements
d'alsace et pour la moselle donc il ya
vraiment des curiosités je me demande si
le gouvernement n'est pas en train de
confondre le mieux et le bien oui une
loi de portée trop générale alors que
son objectif c'est 10 et répétée par le
gouvernement c'est avant tout lutter
contre l'islamisme radical
et de fait ça va porter sur l'ensemble
des églises se fit prime à moi moi je
crois que notre rôle de législateur
c'est d'agir quand il ya des
dysfonctionnements
aujourd'hui comme l'a dit le président à
kenner on observe des dysfonctionnements
qui apporte des perturbations à la
république des menaces quelquefois pour
la république sont source de menace pour
la république
voilà dans un type de religion
évidemment radical dans une politique et
qui n'a rien à voir avec la foi
d'ailleurs bien souvent c'est le
prétexte voilà qui est qu'ils aient
trouvé pour pour générer ces
dysfonctionnements il faut nommer les
choses voilà et les équilibres qui ont
été trouvés en 1905 qui vont
parfaitement depuis un siècle à tout le
monde il faut les consolider il faut les
laisser tranquilles ces précieux parce
que c'est presque unique cc c'est une
pépite française de la république
française que de permettre cette laïcité
que de permettre cet équilibre et bien
voilà il faut lutter contre tous les
aspects radicaux tout ce qui met à mal
la tranquillité la solidité de notre
république nommé ces choses permettre
effectivement on voit bien que le
ministre de l'intérieur à des
difficultés techniques juridiques a
fermé par exemple à certain nombre de
lieux de culte musulmans où s'exerce
plutôt que la religion
un culte au jaillir politiques
pratiquement bon et bien voilà donnons
nos donner au gouvernement les moyens
d'agir
et puis nous consoliderons à ce que nous
avons plus précieux qu'ils s'étaient qui
libre entre la loi et la fois depuis
1905 très très rapidement pas très
simplement que monsieur macron se
prétend être un très grand libéral
économiquement et philosophiquement en
fait quand on regarde son bilan déjà
aujourd'hui il a attaqué la loi de 1881
sur la liberté de la presse donc un
article 24 de l'autre sur des global il
s'attaque la loi 1901 en matière de
liberté associative de 1905 sur la
laïcité je dire le bilan va être
extrêmement rude par rapport à ces
atteintes permanentes aux libertés qui
font la richesse de notre république et
en tous temps à parler on va parler d'un
autre thème qui a également marqué cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est un thème
incontournable depuis un an
la politique vaccinale la stratégie
sanitaire écoutez olivier ferrand tout à
l'heure lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
j'ai comme beaucoup d'entre vous des
remontées de médecins qui ça qui
s'alarment en disant on aura donc pas de
nom ce qui a été dit au médecin
c'est que la semaine suivante les
livraisons par le laboratoire
astrazeneca ont été réduites je le dis
et je le déplore comme peau de chagrin
au lieu et place des 765 mille doses que
nous avons donc livré sur notre
territoire cette semaine il y aura la
semaine prochaine quelques 260 280 mille
doses seulement deux vaccins livrés et
donc nous avons dit aux médecins qu'ils
sont nombreux à être volontaire et que
nous n'avons pas assez de vaccins pour
leur fournir des doses
en conséquence la semaine suivante est
donc cette semaine ils vont chercher
leur dose comme prévu il vaccine la
semaine prochaine par contre ils ne
peuvent pas commandé pour la semaine
prochaine parce que nous n'avons pas ces
doses en plus des médecins il fallait
permettre aux pharmaciens de commencer à
vacciner pour permettre à tous les
patients sur tout le territoire national
ou de bénéfice net
en 2000 pharmaciens sur les 20000
existant qui en l'espace de deux jours
se sont portés volontaires
c'est une bonne nouvelle il ya de la
place pour tout le monde allez si on
résume ce que nous a dit olivier ferrand
sophie primas il n'y a pas de quoi qui a
pas de cafouillage
les médecins libéraux n'ont pas annulé
leur rendez-vous pour vacciner parce
qu'il ya un manque de stocks et non les
pharmaciens les médecins tout le monde
pourra vacciner
bon moi ce que je voudrais dire là
dessus c'est qu'on finit par plus rien
comprendre je vous dis il ya eu un très
belle opération n'en parlait à l'instant
est le président caennais recettes 7 ce
week-end sur une opération de masse dans
nos lacs cynodrome c'est un modèle
depuis le début d'un demi million women
and vaccine début on réclame quelque
chose donc ses traces et si c'est
possible et on me réclame une stratégie
claire au gouvernement de commander des
vaccins et laissez nous organiser des
vaccinodromes où les habitants où les
français sauront exactement où aller
s'ils peuvent pas y aller les
collectivités les emmèneront ou en
mobilisera les vétérinaires les
pharmaciens les médecins les
sages-femmes on mobilisera tous - et on
sera parfaitement faire comme les états
unis qu'à vacciner 30 millions
d'américains en quelques semaines avec
des vaccinodromes des drive
vaccinodromes etc
on saura faire donc que le gouvernement
s'occupe de commander des vaccins qui
s'occupe qu'ils arrivent dans et puis on
s'occupera du reste leur demander
d'arrêter de froid nécessaire via des
emprunts nécessaires avec les services
de l'état déconcentré d'ailleurs parce
que les délégués départementaux de la rs
les préfets sont à la manoeuvre avec les
élus locaux et franchement ça marche
bien et le week-end c'est ça que ça nous
a appris si on veut on peut
patrick kanner si on veut on peut
continuer comme ce week-end le problème
c'est que monsieur véran a raison tout
le temps surtout et contre tout le monde
une pointe d'ironie dans votre qu'il n'y
a jamais de duch quad faut virer les
mondes du gouvernement donc il doit
défendre c'est la politique de ses
patrons mais honnêtement on est
aujourd'hui à 4 millions de français qui
ont reçu une dose 2 millions qui ont
reçu les deux doses
donc ça progresse mais ça progresse
vraiment lentement il ya eu quand même
des erreurs au démarrage chacun le
reconnaît
donc moi ce que j'aimerais seulement ce
gouvernement nous dise la vérité en
disant oui on a des problèmes de
fourniture et pourquoi vouloir
infantiliser des français en leur disant
mais tout ira mieux demain
ça a été mieux ce week-end mais
l'hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
manifestement mais apparemment il ya
encore des stocks a new day et les rangs
il ya de quoi faire mais d'aider des
vaccins stocker ça ne m'intéresse pas à
moi ce que je veux c'est des vaccins
injectés et de faire confiance comme le
dit très bien suivi prima aux locaux aux
forces locales qui finalement sont là
pour être disponible et puis autre chose
qui est aussi liée à la politique
vaccinale
c'est que les confinements partiel à
terme intermittent 1 comme on dirait
dans le monde de la culture
personne n'y comprend rien mon chez moi
je suis dans une région les autres
français j'ai quand même des mesures
territorialisée qui sont en train de
mourir et avec de la cohérence avec de
la cohérence savez c'est très difficile
pour moi d'expliquer à des habitants de
ma région en cette période qui touche
une période pré-électorale que lila il
ya d'un côté des gens confiné mais qu'à
100 m ils ne sont pas mais c'est les
même bassin de vie
donc il dézingue cohérence le
gouvernement va s'expliquer très
prochainement puisque nous allons voir
une commission parlementaire donc de
deux liaisons avec monsieur castaic donc
on va lui reposer la question
la navigation à vue permettez-moi de le
dire ça fait quand même un an qu'on la
subit
dans cette crise sanitaire exactement un
an moi je le regrette et derrière ça je
pense quand même au bientôt 90 mille
décès liés à la pandémie
benjamin morel on entend à l'opposition
toujours assez sévère avec le
gouvernement sur la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire on a une impression qui
a eu un bon coup de com ce week-end et
puis suivi d'une forme de quoi qu'un
avec ces histoires de stocks que les
médecins libéraux peut-être n'avait plus
et donc ces rendez vous qu'ils devaient
annuler oui vous êtes dans une gestion
très politique de la crise c'est à dire
que gros sur l'eau quand olivier vers on
dit que vous avez une politique
aujourd'hui qu'ils étendent suis tendu
avec un système vaccinale qui en
lui-même ne marche pas si mal
c'est en grand partie vrai et dire que
les collectivités territoriales en la
matière
nous comprenons l'ensemble des pays
européens la politique vaccinale elle
est gérée par les états en période de
crise c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique j'irai même d' extrêmement
classique
en revanche vous avez une politique de
communication fondamentalement erratique
sur le flux tendu
vous avez en effet une question qui se
pose au niveau de l'union européenne
avec un débat qui a lieu notamment en
allemagne avec des attaques assez vive
sur le fonctionnement de la politique
vaccinale en europe que nous n'avons pas
en france où réflexe peut-être un peu
ces artistes on regarde toujours vers le
président de la république qui promet
qu'il fera tout et qu'il est le maître à
bord mais qui en fait n'est pas maître
de tout dans cette crise n'est pas
maître de l'évolution d'épidémie il
n'est pas non plus mettre des commandes
aujourd'hui en tout cas de manière
marginale donc là il ya un réflexe
politique qui conduit également à une
polarisation politique de l'opinion ce
qui explique également l'aspect on va
dire très critiques de l'opposition et
de l'autre côté une majorité qui tombe
en pâmoison chaque fois que le ministre
ouvre la bouche pour justifier une
politique évidemment a connu des avants
dans les enquêtes d'opinion quand vous
regardez un petit peu l'opinion des
français sur aujourd'hui la politique
sanitaire du gouvernement
vous voyez que plus vous rapprochez
l'électorat de la république en marche
plus vous trouvez que cette politique
est merveilleuse que vous vous en
éloigner plus vous trouvez que cette
politique et cataclysmique
donc il y a une approche dans tous les
pays européens mais par clairement en
france très politicienne de la gestion
de crise ce qui est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui à la fois pour rendre
audible et solutions mais également pour
tenter de trouver un consensus national
sur ses solutions
eh bien merci merci beaucoup benjamin on
va passer à une autre thématique une
thématique continue c'est sa lé bien du
monde de la culture un très durement
frappés par cette crise sanitaire il ya
une question à ce sujet lors de la
séance de questions d'actu et tout de
suite on va rejoindre steve jours dans
un car vous êtes avec le président de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation laurent laffont et laurent
laffont bonjour mobilisation
actuellement de trois théâtres nationaux
les manifestants qui demandent une
réouverture des lieux culturels vous
soutenez ce mouvement c'est difficile de
ne pas soutenir le mouvement
d'expression qui revendique que la
culture reprenne sa place oui je le
soutiens je pense que
tout ça correspond une inspiration en
très large plus le temps passe plus
cette aspiration prendre l'important
c'est qu'elles revêtent aujourd'hui la
forme d'occupation de lieux de culture à
partir du moment où où l'esprit de cette
occupation est irrespectueuse à la fois
bien sûr des mesures sanitaires mais
aussi de l'idée générale qu'il faut dire
il faut que ça redémarre juifs bien sûr
je soutiens donc vous soutenez aussi la
méthode d'occupation écoutez je pense
que l'on peut difficilement interdire
des gens de s'exprimer
là en l'occurrence là là le moyen de
s'exprimer comme ils peuvent pas
s'exprimer sur scène c'est de s'exprimer
à travers un occupations de lieux à
partir du moment où bien sûr ses
occupations ne sont pas des lieux des
moments de propagation du virus où il ya
des respects des règles sanitaires
et puis que tout ça est fait dans le
respect des uns et des autres oui moi ça
ne s'est pas une quelque chose qui me
choque t on selon vous une réouverture
des lieux culturels est possible dès
demain ça sera au premier ministre de le
dire puisque je crois qu'il s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet je pense qu'il ya
deux types eu de revendications qui sont
faites actuellement par le mini parmi le
milieu culturel
il ya d'abord évidemment la question de
la réouverture des espaces culturels on
comprend bien que c'est compliqué dans
une période où en même temps on nous dit
qu'il ya une recrudescence de l'épidémie
avec la montée en puissance des variants
etc et puis il ya une deuxième
revendication qui est sur la poursuite
de l'année blanche
il me semble que autant sur le premier
revendications
c'est complexe de répondre d c'est
compliqué de répondre aujourd'hui sur ce
sujet autant sur la deuxième ça serait
bien que le gouvernement s'exprime donc
une prolongation de l'année blanche pour
les intermittents à vous êtes favorable
moi j'y suis favorable c'est d'ailleurs
dans l'esprit de ce qui avait été
annoncé il ya plusieurs mois un temps
que l'activité n'est pas reprise n'a pas
redémarré il faudra prolonger l'année
blanche
on voit bien qu'elle n'a pas repris
malheureusement on n'a pas de calendrier
ça serait une mesure de
nécessaire pour rassurer tous ces gens
qui diminue de la culture et ces
manifestants demandent également et bien
des mesures d'urgence face à la
précarité du monde culturel ce qui les
aides actuelles sont suffisantes
écoutez il faut regarder profession par
profession parce que c'est la difficulté
de raisonner de façon très générique sur
l'ensemble du milieu culturel
il ya des activités dans le milieu
culturel qui continue je pense aux
tournages de films par exemple
et puis on a d'autres pour lequel les
dispositifs mis en place sont plus
effectif plus opérationnelles que que
dans d'autres aspects que dans d'autres
activités culturelles donc je pense
qu'il faut faire une analyse assez fine
des choses pour bien ça vous pour bien
identifier et éventuellement des poches
qui pourrait être passé entre les
mailles d'aidé de tous les systèmes de
protection et d'être mise en place une
analyse au cas par cas merci beaucoup
laurent lafon remercie d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci merci steve on l'a tout de suite
rejoindre quentin calais parce
qu'effectivement je le disais il ya une
question à ce sujet lors de la séance à
l'instant et notamment et bien on a
entendu roselyne bachelot qui elle est
plutôt défavorable à l'occupation des
lieux de culture et l
elle répondait au sénateur communiste
pierre ouzoulias ce oui tout à fait je
vous refaire le feuilleton autour de
cette question effectivement table c'est
une question de pierre ouzoulias saint
sénateurs d'ile-de-france et communistes
il s'est fait l'écho d'appel au secours
du monde de la culture ces derniers
jours avec cette image que je voulais
vous montrer que vous avez déjà vu à
l'instant à l'antenne de public sénat
mais je voulais expliqué c'est l'un des
trois théâtres nationaux en l'occurrence
c'est le théâtre de l'odéon à quelques
pas du sénat qui est occupé depuis
plusieurs jours par les intermittents du
spectacle et des artistes
donc vous voyez sur ces images de
gaspard flamand et de centres à cerca
donc pierre ouzoulias s'il a voulu se
faire l'écho de ces mobilisations avec
une comparaison dans l'hémicycle tout à
leur écoute et le sénateur communiste
monsieur le premier ministre regardez
cet hémicycle un fauteuil sur deux et
laissé libre sous la haute autorité du
président larcher
nous respectons en ce lieu les normes
sanitaires
il le sénat n'est pas un foyer
épidémique la culture
n'est pas accessoire secondaire ou
subalterne
elle est essentielle car elle constitue
l'essence même de notre nation
à ce moment la pierre aux liens ça a été
applaudi sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle elle à l'exception bien sûr
des drm r&d pays et donc c'est roselyne
bachelot la mise de la culture qui a
répondu au sénateur on écoute je veux
dire une chose très importante c'est que
l'occupation des lieux de culture n'est
pas le bon moyen cette inutile car les
difficultés du monde de la culture nous
les connaissons mais ces manoeuvres sont
dangereuses elles sont dangereuses car
elles mettent en menace des lieux
patrimoniaux fragile nous avons besoin
de travailler avec les artistes nous les
protégeons et nous continuerons à les
protéger
elle a évoqué deux autres informations
elle a rappelé qu en europe 85% des
lieux de culture était fermée et elle a
ajouté qu'aucun autre pays au monde ne
protéger autant ces artistes et
intermittents que la france ait enfin
une dernière info tam une réunion doit
se tenir demain autour du premier
ministre est donc avec roselyne bachelot
et les acteurs les différents acteurs du
monde de la culture et on devrait avoir
des annonces à ce moment là demain en
fin de matinée
merci merci beaucoup courtin pour toutes
ces explications nous reste quelques
minutes patrick kanner nous ne
reviendrons pas sur les droits des
intermittents a dit roselyne bachelot
qui en même temps s'est aussi opposée à
l'occupation des lieux de culture qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette réponse
de la ministre
déjà c'est bien de confirmer qu'il y
aurait une protection nommé blanche pour
les intermittents je vous rappelle quand
même qu'ils sont 260 milles en france et
je n'oublie pas les 270 mille autres
artistes auteurs donc ces 2 3 à 2 3% du
produit intérieur brut dans le pays
donc il faut protéger cette activité
culturelle mais qui est aussi économique
et social mais je pense que la madame
bachelot l'a est un petit peu débordé
quoi je lui dis très très simplement
on a bien vu que tout l'hémicycle
presque tous les musiques étaient
favorables à la réouverture organisé
structuré des lieux de culture voilà
notre collègue de bias a posé la bonne
question n'a pas eu la bonne réponse
manifestement et je regrette une forme
d'entêtement sur voile à l'ouverture des
lieux culturels par le par le
gouvernement très honnêtement
aujourd'hui les français ont besoin de
vivre tout simplement
et le métro boulot dodo ça ne pourra pas
durer très longtemps je le crains une
forme d'entêtement nous dit patrick
kanner de la part du gouvernement
roselyne bachelot qui a ajouté que 85%
des citoyens européens vivent dans un
régime aux verts effectivement les lieux
de culture sont fermées donc nous ne
sommes pas une exception parce que c'est
une un argument vous entendez oui ce jeu
je l'entends pas tellement parce qu'en
fait moi je pense qu'on est un moment de
cette crise et ça va rejoindre le
premier sujet qu'on a traitées où la
violence est en train de monter et
clairement l'enfermement des français
est en train de monter la culture c'est
une soupape c'est notre identité c'est
une soupape très importante pour toutes
les catégories tous les âges de français
très honnêtement les manifestations
qu'on voit à l'odéon elle met pas en
péril le théâtre de l'odéon
il faut laisser les artistes s'exprimer
ils sont protégés le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il allait continuer à les
protéger financièrement
maintenant faut leur permettre de
travailler il faut permettre aux
français dans des conditions de sécurité
sanitaire de recommencer il s'agit pas
d'ouvrir les discothèques avec 5000
personnes les unes sur les autres ou ou
toute autre forme de d'amusement ou
doudou de culture mais les musées les
théâtres avec un fauteuil sur trois les
cinémas avec un fauteuil sur deux est ré
ouvre on respire on parce que parce
qu'on va étouffer
il ne reste vraiment 15 secondes je cite
camus tout ce qui dégrade la culture
raccourci les chemins qui mènent à la
servitude
voilà nous sommes déficitaires ce qui
met tout le monde d'accord
on va tout de suite et bien conclure on
rejoint en rejoignant à nouveau steve
jourdain mais avec la ministre elisabeth
morano ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
alors que et bien c'était la journée des
droits des femmes
il ya deux jours le 9 mars exactement
oui les abeilles moreno bonjour ministre
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes en cette période on parle
beaucoup de violence conjugale en cette
période de confinement et de couvre-feu
est ce que vous avez des chiffres pour
ce début d'année
absolument a lorsqu'il faut savoir déjà
que c'est que cette période de crise
sanitaire a véritablement vu une
explosion des violences intrafamiliales
pendant le premier confinement elles ont
augmenté de 42 % et le nombre d'appels
sur la plateforme
arrêtons les violences point gouv.fr où
le nombre de chat plutôt à augmenter de
60% donc on sait que cette promiscuité à
créer vraiment des tensions entre les
familles il y a quand même un
encouragement sur le nombre de
féminicide parce qu'en 2019 on en avait
146 en 2020 ce il ya eu 90 femmes qui
sont mortes ou sous le coup de leur
conjoint de leur ex conjoint
on ne peut pas se réjouir de ce nombre
de ce gérant de nom parce que même un
féminicide est un féminicide de trop et
donc le gouvernement doit continuer à
lutter contre ce fléau par toutes les
mesures que nous avons prises dans le
web dans le grenelle des violences
notamment les 46 mesures dont 100 % sont
aujourd'hui mises en oeuvre et nous
travaillons ardemment avec les
associations et aussi avec les
entreprises pour faire en sorte que ce
fléau
un jour soit totalement éradiquée lors
notre sujet qui vous intéresse c'est la
parité hommes femmes dans le cabinet d'
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui il ya douze
hommes pour une seule femme c'est pas
très exemplaire tout ça alors je vais
vous répondre que je n'ai pas vu j'ai 50
ans je n'ai pas vu un gouvernement qui
se soit saisi de manière aussi
volontariste de la question de la parité
des femmes que ce soit dans la société
que ce soit dans la politique que ce
soit dans l'économie le grenelle est là
pour en témoigner
l'index égalité professionnelle est là
aujourd'hui les parlementaires de la
majorité ont déposé une proposition de
loi pour aller encore plus loin et
donner aux femmes toute la place qu'elle
mérite dans notre société
nous avons pour la première fois un
gouvernement à 51 % de femmes
comment vous dire moi je crois davantage
aux actes qu profession de foi
et là les faits parlent pour nous
justement les faits le cabinet donc des
manuels
on n'est pas totalement paritaire vous
parliez de cette proposition de loi qui
vise à imposer des quotas dans les
entreprises ses côtés il existe déjà
pour les conseils d'administration il
faut donc les généraliser selon vous
grâce à la loi copé zimmermann
nous sommes passés en dix ans de 9% dans
les conseils d'administration à 45%
donc cette loi a prouvé que lorsqu'on
est et volontariste on pouvait y arriver
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui elizabeth
borgne a présenté les chiffres de
l'index égalité professionnelle qui
force les entreprises à publier les
indicateurs qui nous permettent de voir
si la parité augmente dans les
entreprises et force est de constater
que nous n'avons que 2 % de nos
entreprises en france aujourd'hui qui
arrive à une parité parfaite ou en leur
sein ça veut dire que 98% des
entreprises ont encore un travail
colossal à faire il ya encore 13 % de
nos entreprises qui oublient d'augmenter
les femmes qui rentrent de congé
maternité alors même que c'est légal
moi je pense que tant qu'on a mis en
place je pense que tant qu'on n'aura pas
mis en place un objectif chiffré qui
permettent de mesurer l'équilibré ou
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans l'entreprise
on n'y arrivera pas et on part de
tellement loin c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le c'est le forum économique
mondial qui dit qu'il va falloir
attendre
deux cent cinquante sept ans au niveau
planétaire pour arriver à une parité
juste et réelle même si en europe ses 54
ans est ce que vous pensez que la jeune
génération aura la patience d'attendre
54 ans avant d'avoir la possibilité de
s'émanciper de réaliser sa carrière
professionnelle et de se dire qu'elle a
les mêmes droits qu'un homme je ne crois
pas dans la ministre petite dernière
question est ce qu'une femme à l'elysée
en 2022 est souhaitable à ce que ça fera
avancer la cause des femmes
moi je pense que en ce moment compte
tenu de la situation dans laquelle notre
pays est ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
de quelqu'un qui est un leader et qui
sache emmener notre pays en dehors de la
crise que nous traversons et je pense qu
emmanuel macron est la meilleure
personne pour ça merci beaucoup madame
la ministre aurait ressenti à mes
questions merci à vous merci beaucoup du
primat ya encore bien du chemin à faire
pour arriver à l'égalité femmes hommes
dans le monde dans les entreprises et
puis on a rappelé aussi bien sûr un
c'est terrible chiffres des violences
faites aux femmes
en ces deux sujets un petit peu
différemment
évidemment sur la parité que la semaine
où on parle de doué mais moi je suis
assez favorable effectivement à ce qu'on
publie un certain nombre d'un decs avec
les précautions d'usagé mais je suis
aussi assez favorable à ce qu'on montre
les femmes qui sont des étendards par
leurs compétences par leur qualité par
leur volontarisme voilà il ya plein de
femmes aujourd'hui qui sont dans le
milieu de l'entreprise et qui sont des
exemples c'est elle qu'il faut montrer
davantage plus que des indicateurs
favorables je crois que je prends à la
vertu de l'exemple je crois à la vertu
du travail des compétences et puis il
faut mettre en place les conditions pour
que les femmes puissent aller travailler
et les hommes et les femmes puissent
aller travailler
libérés d'un certain nombre de
contingence que nous avons tous voilà il
faut mettre en place toutes les
structures familiales pour que les
hommes les femmes puissent être
effectivement capacité à égalité voilà
de pouvoir travailler et assumer le rôle
et on avait une sorte de confinement que
c'est encore loin d'être le cas et au
lieu les femmes assurent encore
énormément les tâches ménagères
il ya aussi une proposition de loi qui
serait pas dans les rangs de l arm pour
instaurer des quotas pour établir la
parité dans les instances dirigeantes à
ce que vous y êtes favorable patrick
kanner enfin je sais que en politique en
tout cas ce les quotas ont permis
d'aboutir la parité dont donc très
concrètement et j'appartiens une
formation politique qui a notamment la
dernière
le dernier exemple en date a permis la
parité dans les départements n'y avait
que 13 % de femmes dans les départements
avoir la loi que j'ai soutenu comme
président de conseil général à l'époque
conseil général du nord
aujourd'hui il ya 50% de femmes dans les
départements donc oui un moment donné il
faut être non seulement accompagnant
mais peut-être forcer un peu le destin
est ce que vous êtes d'accord là-dessus
benjamin morel faut-il et bien instaurer
des quotas pour pouvoir satisfaire ses
objectifs de parité on est quand même un
anniversaire de la loi copé zimmermann
qui montre qu'il ya encore bien du
chemin à faire avant d'y arriver dans
les entreprises notamment les quotas
sont un bon moyen évidemment après ce
que l'on remarque quand on regarde un
peu les études étrangères c'est qu'il
faut pas utiliser un effet masquant
c'est à dire que quand vous instaurer
des quotas dans un certain nombre de
secteurs vous parler notamment du
conseil d'administration eh bien vous
favoriser l'accès égalitaire des femmes
et des hommes dans un lieu qui est un
mieux pouvoir mais pas forcément ensuite
les rapports internes qui conduisent à
réellement maîtriser ce pouvoir ailleurs
vous avez d'autres champs et bien qu'ils
se sont touchés que de manière incidente
donc c'est un travail beaucoup plus sur
le fond un tout à l'heure a été évoqué
notamment les questions qui ont trait à
la gestion de la vie de famille
acceptera à côté à côté de l'emploi les
grandes différences entre la france et
l'allemagne notamment c'est un peu une
tarte à la crème de le dire tellement
c'est quelque chose qui est ancré dans
la culture allemande
mais c'est justement la possibilité en
france pour des raisons culturelles mais
également au regard du développement de
politiques publiques à destination de la
petite enfance et bien aux fans
françaises de bien plus travaillé qu'en
allemagne
donc là vous avez un élément qui est un
élément sur lequel peu de jouer les
pouvoirs publics pour permettre et bien
une meilleure égalité homme femme les
quotas c'est important et je suis
d'accord c'est nécessaire mais c'est
malheureusement pas suffisant comment
jugez-vous à la politique du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron en la
matière on se rappelle que c'était là
une l'une des grandes causes du
quinquennat avec on a entendu un steve
un petit peu asticoter
la ministre sur le fait que le
gouvernement en tout cas au sein de ces
instances à l'elysée ne s'applique pas
forcément toujours ses règles oui enfin
ça c'était dans dans beaucoup de
gouvernements c'est le cas dans le
gouvernement avait toujours une très
très bonne volonté au départ et puis les
réflexes reviennent assez vite
non moi je crois qu'il faut sur ces
sujets là qui sont des sujets par
exemple sur les violences faites aux
femmes
essayez là aussi de sortir des postures
politiques là aussi de sortir des effets
d annonce et de travailler vraiment dans
le fond là aussi avec les collectivités
territoriales moi j'ai été maire d'une
commune y avait des violences de mai
dans ma dans ma ville je m'appuyais à la
fois sur les forces bien sûr de police
municipale mais de police de justice
avec un traitement cas par cas de chacun
des foyers de repérage des femmes en
difficulté c'est un travail de fond il
faut aider les collectivités
territoriales là dessus voilà on est
loin des effets d'annoncé on est sur un
travail de fourmi un travail qui doit
être supportée à la fois financièrement
juridiquement et dans des groupes
paritaires j'allais dire avec les
services de l'état les services
collectivités territoriales un travers
socia tiff de longue haleine et de
fourmi mais refoulé beaucoup patrick
anna merci sophie primas ce avant de
participer à ce débrief un mot sur cette
jonquilles que je porte aujourd'hui
cette gentil contre le cancer l'institut
curie appel à la mobilisation du 9 au 21
mars vous pouvez faire un don soit sur
le site une jonquille contre le cancer
point fr soit en envoyant par sms espoir
aux 92 0 02 pour les sportifs vous
pouvez aussi courir marcher avec dans
votre poche votre smartphone et
l'application courgeon quilles pour
chaque kilomètre parcouru 1 euro sera
reversé à l'institut curie
mais ni
[Musique]